COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES.
COMPLIANCE OF THOSE ORDERS AS
SOON AS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NOR PRACTICES IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WITH ADMIN
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
HEARING ROOM SIXTH AT THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW WILL BE USING.
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WHISK
pINDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN- ANNOUNCE IT. NOW
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 THE ACCESS CODE IS.
NINE ONE ONE EIGHT NINE TWO
EIGHT FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCE
SYSTEM WORKS PLEASE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY THE MODERATE
DIAL ONE AND ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR THE
OPERATOR ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THERE MAY BE A SHORT
WAITING PERIOD ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU'LL BE ON MUTE IT
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER
FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING OR LISTENING ON PARTY
YOU'RE GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IS IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE HEARING
SERVICE OR HAVE THE CONNECTION
MUTED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HIRING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY THE
MAYBE SOME LAG TIMES. DISPENSER
JUST THE NEW USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL PATIENT. SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. ALL RIGHT- FIRST- DUTA
TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS I'M INSTITUTING TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED AN EQUAL
AMOUNT OF TIME WHICH IS TWO
WITNESSES FOR TWO MINUTES EACH
ALL THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
THEIR NAME. AFFILIATION
IMPOSITION ON MEASURES I WANNA
MAKE IT CLEAR UP FRONT THAT
APARTMENT EACH SIDE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AT TWO PRIMARY
WINCES EACH PRIMARY WITNESS
WILL BE PERMITTED TO TESTIFY
FOR TWO MINUTES TWO MINUTES.
THAT'S IT I WILL THEN
ADDITIONALLY PERMIT EACH SIDE
HAVE A MAX OF FIFTEEN MINUTES
FOR WITNESSES WHO MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR- NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION-
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATION
BILLS LET'S STILL SCORE
MANAGING COUNSEL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM- BERG
HERE. AMBERG HERE BOARD YES.
BARGES PRESENT COPY AT ALL DID
I FILL IT OUT SO HERE GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HERE HERTZBERG. JONES
JONES HERE LAYERED LAYERED HERE
STERN WHITE HOUSE SKI. WHITE
HOUSE SKI HERE WEINER. I YOU
HAVE A FORUM THANK YOU MADAM
CHIEF COUNSEL- WE HAVE NINE
BILLS IN TODAY'S AGENDA THREE
WHICH ARE ON CONSENT THAT IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ARE AS
FOLLOWS PHONE NUMBER THREE A.
B. TWO NINE EIGHT BY SEVEN
MEMBER- WENT WITH THE MEMBERS
FILE NUMBER FOR A. B. FIVE ONE
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD.
WITH AMENDMENTS FILE NUMBER SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA IS
EMOTIONALLY CONCERNED COUNTER
SENATOR LAYERED MOVES THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MAN CHIEF
COUNSEL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AMBERG
YOU'RE. UP HI AM BERG HI HI OR
I YET. DID US I DID I SO I GO
INSIDE HI ONCE OTHERS I BERG
JONES HI JOE I LAYERED ON A
LAYERED ICE. BY CAL SKI HI MY
CASKET I. YOU HAVE TO ZERO SO.
ALREADY WILL PUT CAN ON CALL-
SIMPLY MEMBERS STONE IS BEEN
PATIENTLY WAITING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE- AB TWO
SIX ZERO ARE YOU PREPARED YES
YOU ARE I AM THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND SENATORS
THIS BILL IS A BILL THAT IS
TRYING TO CLOSE SOME OF THE
GAPS WITHIN. THE WAY CHILDREN
WHO ARE ABUSED AND NEGLECTED OR
HANDLE IN OUR SYSTEM AND
OFTENTIMES. IT DEPENDENCY
SYSTEM INTERESTING ENOUGH WANTS
TO SEND THEM TO PROBATE TO
CREATE THE GUARDIANSHIP THEN
THE PROBLEMS WITH THAT OR THAT
THOSE CHILDREN THAT. DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO ALL OF THE
SERVICES THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO THEM. UNDER THE
DEPENDENCY SYSTEM. ANY SPECIAL
INCLUDING WHEN THEY BECOME. OR
WOULD OTHERWISE BE NON MINOR
DEPENDENTS AGE OUT ESSENTIALLY
OF THE DEPENDENCY SYSTEM THERE
THAT PRECLUDED FROM ALL OF THE
BENEFITS AND OPPORTUNITIES
WHETHER IT'S HOUSING OR MONEY
SUPPORT OR OTHERS THAT. THAT
THEY CAN GET IN THAT SYSTEM.
AND THAT'S A REAL CHALLENGE FOR
THEM WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
ENSURE THAT THEIR SUCCESS SO
WHAT THIS BILL IS DOING. IS IN
CLARIFYING THAT EVEN WHEN THAT
HAPPENS THAT THE CASES REFERRED
TO PROBATE TO CREATE A
GUARDIANSHIP THEIR- AT THE
DEPENDENCY COURT DOES NOT LOSE
JURISDICTION. THEY CAN STILL
OPEN A CASE THEY CAN STILL.
PROTECT THAT CHILD TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE SYSTEM IS SET
UP TO PROTECT THEM AND- THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE. OFTENTIMES A SOCIAL
WORKER IN THESE CASES THAT IS
MAKING A RECOMMENDATION TO
PROBATE. WILL DECLINE TO WANT
TO HAVE THAT CASE FILED. WE
WANTED THE PROBATE JUDGE TO
LOOK AT THAT CASE LOOK AT
WHAT'S IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE CHILD. AND MAKING
APPROPRIATE REFERRALS THAT'S
REALLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
THIS IS BEEN A BILL THAT'S GONE
THROUGH SMOOTHLY UP TO THIS
POINT. AND IT'S NOW GARNER SOME
OPPOSITION. FROM THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR LESBIAN RIGHTS AND-
FRANKLY. I TAKE THEIR POINTS IN
THEIR POINTS OR- ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT ESPECIALLY
QUEER KIDS HAVE IN THE
DEPENDENCY SYSTEM. AND THEY'RE
NOT WRONG IN. INTERPRETING
THOSE CHALLENGES IN IN AND
ASKING FOR SOME HELP BUT THAT'S
REALLY NOT THIS BILL. AND THE
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE AROUND
THE DEPENDENCY SYSTEM. DOES
CONTINUE TO WORK IN ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'M VERY HEARTENED
BY. HISTHE CURRENT BUDGET
PROPOSAL THEY WERE NOT WORKING
ON THAT SPENDS A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY AND EXPAND THE
CAPACITY. FOR USE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES. AND THE GOAL
ALWAYS IS TO NOT HAVE TO SEND
KIDS TO THE DEPENDENCY SYSTEM
FRANKLY WERE THE DELINQUENCY
SYSTEM IF WE CAN HELP IT. AND
THAT'S WE DO THAT BY PROVIDING
SERVICES THOSE KIDS UP FRONT.
AND EARLY ON. A LOT OF COUNTIES
HAVE WHAT THEY CALL A
DIFFERENCE RESPONSE. PROGRAM
WHERE THEY'RE DEALING WITH
FAMILIES BEFORE THERE'S GOING
TO BE NEED TO REMOVE A CHILD.
THAT'S THE BEST OUTCOME AND I
THINK. THAT'S WHAT THE
OPPOSITION'S REALLY POINTING TO
OR BETTER OUTCOMES FOR KIDS
HAPPEN IF WE NEVER HAVE TO
BRING THEM. INTOA SYSTEM THAT
DOES PROVE TO BE DIFFICULT FOR
A LOT OF THE KIDS THAT ENTER
INTO IT. BUT THERE ARE SOME
BENEFITS AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT DECISIONS IN THE
LEGAL SYSTEM ARE BEING MADE TO
APPROPRIATELY. ABOUT THAT
CHILD. AND THAT THEY WILL
ALWAYS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
BENEFITS OF THE DEPENDENCY
SYSTEM. EVEN AS WE WORK TO
IMPROVE THE DEPENDENCY SYSTEM.
AND GET THOSE BENEFITS LONG
TERM AND NOT UNNECESSARILY
EXCLUDED FROM THINGS I CAN GAP
IN OTHERS. WHERE THEY WOULD
HAVE SOME LEG UP AS THEY AGE
OUT OF THE SYSTEM SO THAT'S
REALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS DOING
AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION. MAYBE
THERE'S SOME CLARIFICATIONS ARE
THINGS BUT AGAIN WE'RE NOT.
THIS BILL'S NOT FIXING OVERALL
THE DEPENDENCY SYSTEM EVEN WITH
SOME OF THE CHALLENGE THEY NEED
TO BE MADE WHAT WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO DO IS ENSURE THAT.
THAT THE PROBATE COURTS OUR
THIRD PERFECTED LEE INSURING
THAT REFERRALS TO DEPENDENCY.
CAN HAPPEN WHEN THEY NEED TO
HAPPEN SO RIGHT WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THEY DO HAVE
A COUPLE OF WITNESSES WITH US.
SABRINA FORTE FROM THE ALLIANCE
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS ENGINE
REX ROAD FROM THE ALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CARE GIVER. AND
AGAIN I ASK FOR YOUR I. THE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE- MISS
SABRINA FORTY ARE YOU ON THE
PHONE LINE. BUT I BELIEVE THIS
RECORD IS GOING FIRST ALL RIGHT
MISS REX ROAD ARE YOU AVAILABLE.
YEAH ALL RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON
FAMILY MEMBERS DOWN AND- MANY
MEMBERS. I'M JOHN BACKGROUND ON
MAKING THANK YOU TO DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA LATE. VERY AND WE
REPRESENT THE VOICE OF YOUR
INTENTION. TO PROMOTE THE WELL
BEING OF CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE. SO WE HAVE WORKED REALLY
HARD A PATH AND SEVERAL YEARS
EIGHT HILL AND CLEANING SERVICE
AND POLICIES FOR HAN AFTER
FOSTERING KINSHIP FAMILIES. AND
UNFORTUNATELY DURING THAT TIME
WE HAVE MATT BARNES WE HAVE.
ALSO SUPPORTED MANY RELATIVES.
WHO DESPERATELY NEED AND MAKE
LIGHT THAT THAT PART OF THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. BUT BECAUSE
THEY WERE TOLD I THINK FINE. AT
THE TIME THAT MEANT THAT THEY
WOULD NEVER BE THERE- GRAND
CHILDREN FOR EXAMPLE AGAIN. IF
THEY DID NEED- PRINT THAT GO TO
COURT AND- TAKE AND SHE FOR THE
CHILDREN- THAT THE CHILDREN
WOULD BE ABLE IN FOSTER CARE.
SO DURING THE TIME OF CRISIS
MANY OF THESE FAMILIES HAVE
MADE THAT DECISION ONLY TO FIND
AFTER THE FACT THAT THEY DO NOT
QUALIFY AND NOT ASK THAT. THEY
KEEP SERVICES SUPPORT THE WE
WE'VE WORKED REALLY HARD TO
TELL THAT INCLUDING THE CHILD
CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM NOW THE
FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE ATTEND
AND SPECIAL RATE FOR CHILDREN
AND YOU NEED THAT EXTRA CARE.
AND OTHER BEHAVIORAL AND
SUPPORT SERVICES IN ADDITION
AND I'M OLDER YOU FIND THEY
CAN'T ACCESS AND TRENT
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH BENEFIT.
COLLEGE BENEFIT AND BY LYING
AND BOTH CHILDREN AND THEIR
PARENTS DON'T HAVE ACCESS. TO
LEGAL. COUNSEL TO OUR- HE DON'T
READ IN A- PROCESS. I'M SURE WE
ENCOURAGE YOUR IPHONE WE WOULD
LIKE FAMILIES. TO GET ALL OF
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION I'M
ESPECIALLY IF THEIR CHILDREN
HAVE SUFFERED FROM ABUSE AND
NEGLECT. AND REALLY DO YOU NEED
ANY KIND ON THE PURPOSE AND THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM HEELAN
FRIDAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THE
YOU MISS REX. MISS. FOR GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SABRINA
FORTE AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND IMPACT LITIGATION AT
THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS. ALLIANCE IS PROUD TO
SPONSOR THE B. TWO FIFTY WHICH
CLOSES THE- GAP PHILIPPINE
ORDINATION BETWEEN THE PROBATE
AND JUVENILE DEPENDENCY COURTS
IN CASES INVOLVING CHILD ABUSE
AND NEGLECT. WELL PROTECTING
THE DUE PROCESS RIGHTS OF
CHILDREN AND PARENTS. EIGHTY
TWO SIXTY ALSO ENSURES THAT OUR
STATE CAN GAP PROGRAMS SUPPORT
ALL KINSHIP CAREGIVERS AND
DEPENDENCY COURT. WE HAVE HAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS
MEASURE AND IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I WILL MAKE MYSELF
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AS NEEDED.
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
EYEBROWS THANK YOU. DAVIS FOR
DATE OF LET'S TAKE. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SIX ZERO
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
THE CHAMBER IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
TWO SIX ZERO SEEING KNOWING.
ABOUT ROOM ONE TWELVE. NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SIX ZERO. WE
APPRECIATE IT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. TWO SIX ZERO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AT
THIS TIME WE DO HAVE A THREE IN
OUR QUEUE. ALL RIGHTY. WE'LL
START WITH NUMBER FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JENNY **** WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION. OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE CELL.
THANK YOU FOR. NEXT TO NUMBER
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JERRY
SCHROEDER ND I'M A DIRECTOR OF
FOSTER AND KINSHIP CARE
EDUCATION AND ALSO A CALIFORNIA
RESOURCE PARENT AND I'VE ALSO
BEEN A GOOD RELATIVE CARE GIVER
A KINSHIP CARE GIVER INFORMALLY
PLACE WITH MY GRANNY. AND I'M
ABSOLUTELY IN FAVOR OF THIS AND
HAVING WORKED IN THIS INDUSTRY
OF CHILDREN AND FAMILY MEMBERS
THIRTY FIVE ALREADY THANK YOU-
ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE. THE NEXT
TO NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS ANNA FAULKNER
FROM LINCOLN FAMILIES WHICH
PROVIDES PREVENTATIVE SUPPORT
SERVICES THAT THE TRUCK BACK TO
THE PROPERTY IN TRAUMA IN
ALAMEDA AND CONTRA COSTA
COUNTIES I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE THREE HUNDRED KINSHIP
FAMILIES WE SERVE IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND WE URGE THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO FULLY
SUPPORT THE TRICIA BELL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
MODERATOR ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO OTHERS IN THE QUEUE ALL
RIGHT CONTINUE. THANK YOU LET'S
TURN THE OPPOSITION I HAVE
KNOWN LISTED IN PRINCIPLE
OPPOSITION IF YOU ARE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL- I'M LOOKING TO THE
GALLERIA SEE NO WITNESSES
RISING IN OPPOSITION. LOOKING
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE NO ONE
RISING OPPOSITION ROOM ONE
TWELVE LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINE. MODERATOR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE.
OPPOSITION TO AB. TWO SIX ZERO.
AND LATER GERMAN PR IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO SIX ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO PROPOSITION.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NONE IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MODERATOR BACK
TO THE CHAMBER I SEE NO
MICROPHONES RAISED- WITH
RESPECT TO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CONCERNING A B. TWO
SIX ZERO- SEVERAL ACCOUNTS CAN
LOSE THE BILL. SOME OF THEM
RESPONDED WITH CLOSE I JUST ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MAN
CHIEF COUNSEL- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS A B. TWO SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS DOWN WITH
EMOTION BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
HE- THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE AMBERG HI.
AMBER GUY BURGESS ON GORGEOUS I
GOT VIETTO. DID I SO DID I SO
I. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ BY HERTZ
BERG JONES ALL RIGHT JONES I.
IT LAYERED. LAYERED ICE STERN.
WAY CASKEY HI WHY CASKEY I
WINNER. YOU HAVE SEVENTY ZERO
SO FAR. THANK YOU- SILVERSTONE
WILL PLACE ON CALL THANK YOU
SENATOR ALL RIGHT THANKS NEXT
WE HAVE A B. TWO SEVEN TWO BY
SOMEONE OVER KYLIE I DON'T KNOW
IF SOMEONE WERE KYLIE IS
PRESENT. I DON'T SEE HIM I DID
SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES A
SECOND AGO SO IF A SIMILAR
NUMBER KYLIE IS NOT PRESENT
LET'S TURN TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVIES AND A. B. FIVE EIGHT
THREE. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'LL
GO AHEAD- WHAT'S THE PODIUM IS
CLEANED AND HAVE A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVIES PRESENT. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR SENATORS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT
THREE I WANT TO THANK COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH MY STAFF
ON THIS MEASURE. UNDER CURRENT
LAW APPLICANTS FOR MARRIAGE
LICENSE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE REQUIRED TO
APPEAR TOGETHER AND IN PERSON
BEFORE A COUNTY CLERK WHO
VERIFIES THE APPLICANT'S
IDENTITY THROUGH THE
PRESENTATION OF GOVERNMENT ID
WITNESSES THEIR SIGNATURES AND
ADMINISTERS AN OLD. PRIOR TO
ISSUING A HARD COPY MARRIAGE
DOCUMENT THE COUPLE MUST THEN
SEEK OUT A QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL
TO SOME NICE THE MARRIAGE WITH
AT LEAST ONE ADDITIONAL WITNESS
PRESENT AND RETURN THE SIGN
MARRIAGE LICENSE TO THE COUNTY.
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
THE PHYSICAL DISTRESSING AND
PUBLIC HEALTH PROTOCOLS THAT
HAVE COME WITH IT HAVE MADE IT
DIFFICULT IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO MEET THE CURRENT
STATUARY OBLIGATIONS TO
ADMINISTER A VALID AND LEGAL
MARRIAGE. EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
THREE SIX TO CODIFY UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THE PRACTICE
FOR ELECTRONIC ISSUANCE OF
MARRIAGE LICENSES IN SOME
POSITION THIRD ONE IS TO BE
DONE VIA LIVE INTERACTIVE VIDEO
TECHNOLOGY THE CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES HAVE EMPLOYED OVER THE
LAST YEAR DUE TO COPE IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. I WANT TO
ADD THAT THIS PRACTICE IS
COMPLETELY VOLUNTEER AND THE
BILL DOES NOT MANDATE THIS IN
ADDITION THE MEASURE SPECIFIES
A BOTH APPLICANTS MAY NOT BE
MINORS. THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION PATH TO SOMEBODY
SEVENTY FIVE ZERO AND THE
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS WITH ME HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFYREMOTELY IS
LOUISE CARAMANDI FROM SANTA
CLARA COUNTY CLERK'S RECORDING
OFFICE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN A
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVIES- MR KILL.
MONDAY ARE YOU AVAILABLE ON THE
PHONE. MODERATOR IS MISTER OF
LOUIS. HERE ON MONDAY AVAILABLE.
I DO SHOW THEIR CONNECTED-
PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT ON MUTE-
THIS. MR THE AMOUNT THEY DO
HEAR US. THE OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES WHO ARE I A LOOK TO
THE GALLERY TO SEE NO WITNESSES
THE GALLERY WE SHOULD TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT LET'S COME
BACK TO MR KIIR AMANTE CITIES
AVAILABLE. SOME INSECURE MANTE
PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT ON MUTE.
ALL RIGHT- WHAT DO WE DO THIS
MODERATOR LET'S START TAKING
OTHERS IN SUPPORT AND THEN IF
WE HAPPEN UPON MR CARAMANDI
DATE YOU WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES.
BUT THERE'S A SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE LET. ABSOLUTELY JOHN ON
THE PHONE LINE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN SUPPORT. PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE ONE IN
OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATTHEW
CYBERLINK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS I
LIKE TO THINK HE THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL FOR CHAIRING THE VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE FOR US- WE'VE
SPENT THE LAST YEAR. PUTTING
TOGETHER THE BEST PRACTICES
ACROSS THE COUNTIES WERE
ADMINISTERING THESE THESE
REMOTE. CEREMONY IS SET UP FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND WE'VE
HEARD A LOT FROM THEM TO BE
LIKE THAT PROCESS CONTINUE.
THANK YOU AGAIN AND PLEASE-
DRIVER ON THE- THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT YEAR. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. BY
I SEE SENATOR JONES U. S. B.
RECOGNIZE CENTER JONES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST AS A
MAJOR POINT OF ORDER OR TO
HELP- THE AUTHOR IF THAT LAST
WITNESS COULD STAY ON THE LINE
JUST IN CASE WE CAN'T GET THE
FIRST WITNESS- MAYBE THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS IF WE HAVE IT ALL
RIGHT MR SELLING ARE YOU STILL
AVAILABLE YOU ON THE LINE.
STILL. YES AND- I AM ALL RIGHT
GREAT IF THE CENTRE JONES'S ASK
THAT YOU REMAIN. SO IF YOU
COULD DO SO. WE WOULD BE
GRATEFUL- LET'S SEE IF WE CAN
FIND MISTER HERE MONDAY. HI
YEAH SHOW THAT- MR CARAMANDI ON
THE OLD LINE ANYMORE. ALL RIGHT.
IT DROPPED ALL RIGHT WHAT WHY
DON'T WE GO TO OPPOSITION TO MR
CARAMANDI SHOWS UP WE'LL HAVE-
IMPRISONS TESTIMONY ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO TO THE OPPOSITION I
SHOW NO WITNESSES- LISTED IN
OPPOSITION BUT LOOKING TO THE
GALLERIA SEE NO ONE. RISING IN
OPPOSITION TO GARY KNOWN IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE OTHER OTHERS ON
THE PHONE LINE WE SHOULD
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FIVE EIGHT THREE. AND IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THAT TIME THE N.
OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE EIGHT
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NONE IN OUR
QUEUE- HE'S NOT IN YET BUT- IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE LINE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. ANYONE
REMAINING. OTHER THAN MR
SETTLING. AND IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION P. A. B.
FIVE EIGHT THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NONE IN OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT LET
ME RECOGNIZE THE RING BACK THE
CHAMBER LET ME RECOGNIZE
SENATOR JONES THAN SENATOR
BOARD JUST CENTER JONES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND I WILL
DO IS- I'LL JUST ASK THEM ALL
IN IN AT ONCE AND THEN THEN.
MAYBE THE WITNESS FOR THE
AUTHOR CAN. ADDRESS SOME-
BECAUSE THIS IS AN INTERESTING.
IDEA AND- SITUATION SO. NUMBER
ONE HOW DO YOU ENSURE THAT BOTH
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ON THE
TECHNOLOGY ARE ACTUALLY IN
CALIFORNIA. ABOUT WITNESSES-
YOU KNOW CURRENT LAW REQUIRES A
WITNESS. WOULDN'T A WITNESS NO
IF BOTH PARTIES CAN ATTEST TO
THEIR DESIRE TO BE ARRIED OR
HELP COMBAT FRAUD OR IF
SOMEBODY'S BEING COERCED INTO
THE MARRIAGE HAVING THE WITNESS
WOULD CERTAINLY HELP WITH THAT.
AS IT GOES IN THE SECOND ONE
HOW DO YOU ENSURE THAT
SOMEBODY'S NOT- UNDER DURESS IN
IN BEING PUSHED INTO THIS
SITUATION. AND- I HAD A PEANUT
GALLERY OVER HERE. IF THAT'S I
GUESS THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
CRUX OF IT WE APPRECIATE THE
HELP FROM THE OTHER SENATORS
RIGHT- BUT- IF WE COULD ASK
THAT CONVERSATIONS. BE EITHER
IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER
OUTSIDE THE CHAMBER SO SENATOR
JONES IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
HIS QUESTIONS WITHOUT
INTERRUPTION JUST A GREAT
SUMMER AS I GOT THERE OKAY HOW
DO YOU HOW DO YOU ENSURE THAT
BOTH INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE ADDRESS THE WITNESS
SITUATION AND HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT ONE OR BOTH PARTIES ARE
NOT CONSENT ERROR ACTUALLY
CONSENTING TO THE MARRIAGE AND
NOT. BEING COERCED INTO THIS
SITUATION. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
IS SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER BABIES I
UNDERSTAND MR CARAMANDI IS ON
THE LINE SO- IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO RESPOND TO THAT PLEASE GO
AHEAD OR IF YOU PREFER TO DEFER
TO MISTER KERR MONDAY YOU'RE
WELCOME TO DO SO. YOU KNOW WHAT
I'LL DO IF YOU DON'T MIND I'LL
DO BOTH AND I JUST WANTED TO
CITE CIVIL CODE SECTION FIVE BY
FOUR OF THE BILL WHICH READS
EACH MEMBER OF THE COUPLE STUFF
PHYSICALLY. SHOULD BE
PHYSICALLY LOCATED IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WELL USING REMOTE
TECHNOLOGY TO OBTAIN A MARRIAGE
LICENSE PURSUANT TO THIS PART
EACH MEMBER OF THE COUPLE SHALL
BE IN THE SAME PHYSICAL
LOCATION THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL USING. REMOTE A
TECHNOLOGY THE COUNTY CLERK MAY
REQUIRE A COUPLE TO COMPLETE AN
AFFIDAVIT. IN A FORM PROVIDED
BY THE COUNTY CLERK AFFIRMING
THAT THEY ARE IN EACH
INDIVIDUAL PARTICIPATING IN A
MARRIAGE. SOME STATIONS USING
REMOTE TECHNOLOGY ARE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THIS PART. AND
IF I COULD HAVE MY WITNESS
PERHAPS FOLLOW UP THAT BE
GREAT. ALL RIGHT. SECURE MONDAY
UNDERSTAND WE FOUND YOU. MAYBE
NOT. MR KERR HERE ON MONDAY.
NOT THERE. ALL RIGHT WELL IF WE
FIND HIM WE WILL END IN WITH
THE SUPPLEMENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVIES ANSWER YOU MAY DO SO
ALRIGHT SENATOR JONES ANYTHING
FURTHER. WITNESS THAT
OPPORTUNITY MAYBE HE MIGHT HAVE
SOME FUN AT ALL YEAH MR
STARLING ARE YOU AVAILABLE
WOULD YOU CARE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION. YES SIR I MEAN I
THINK DID THE SUMMARY ANSWERED
IT VERY WELL BUT ALSO ADDED. A
NUMBER OF THE COUNTIES. THAT
WENT INTO THIS PROCESS YOU KNOW
THE SORT OF HAD NEEDED DURING
THE STATE HOME OR THE PANDEMIC.
OF FOUND DIFFERENT WAYS TO
VERIFY IDENTITY- AND THE MOST
COMMON ONE THAT THEY USE WITH
HAVING THE APPLICANTS ACTUALLY-
RESPOND VIA MAIL- PRIOR TO THE
CEREMONY THAT WAS SCHEDULED AT
A LATER DATE SO THE CLERK
WOULD. SEND THE APPLICATION
DOWN TO A CALIFORNIA ADDRESS
THE PERSON WOULD HAVE TO.
RECEIVE IT AND THEN BE-
BASICALLY SIDED WITH A WET.
SIGNATURE TO VERIFY THEIR
IDENTITY YOU KNOW AT THAT
ADDRESS- BEFORE APPEARING ON
THE NEW SCREEN. ON A PROJECT
AND- THEN AFTER. THAT WE'LL
EGGS TOOK PLACE- BUT KIND OF
THE POINT OF BILL WAS DEAD FOR
COLLATE ALL THE BEST PRACTICES
NOT. THAT DISCOVERED DURING THE
PANDEMIC THE STATE AND TRY TO.
BRING EVERYBODY UP TO A- SORT
OF BY BUT PRACTICE. PROCESS TO
IF YOU A WIDE ACCOUNTED TO MOVE.
AND DO THAT IN DEATH EVEN AFTER
THIS IS WHAT THE. THANK YOU MR
SORRY. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR JOE.
ANY FURTHER. SERVE OR JUST. I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CONSENTE OPPOSED TO POTENTIALLY
THE QUESTION I WAS GOING TO I'M
GONNA BE SUPPORTING ON THIS
BILL BECAUSE I THINK- IT IT IT
CAN BE HELPFUL. IN A NUMBER OF
INSTANCES- I WOULD SUSPECT
HOWEVER THAT TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
MIGHT BE FURTHER OUT THAN WOULD
BE NECESSARY GIVEN THAT WE'RE
RESPONDING TO THE PANDEMIC BUT
MAYBE I'LL JUST AS A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION. INDIA THE AUTHOR
DOESN'T HAVE TO ANSWER IT MAYBE
IN HER CLOTHES IF SHE WISHES
THROUGH THE CHAIR- IS WHAT ARE
THE SAFEGUARDS. THAT WOULD BE
PUT IN PLACE TO AUTHENTICATE- A
PERSON'S IDENTITY I THINK THE
SPEAKER. JUST PRIOR JUST KIND
OF GLOSSED OVER IN MADE MENTION
OF IT BUT- MAYBE YOU CAN GO
INTO MORE DETAIL OR HAVE. THAT
INDIVIDUAL. AND THE SECOND. IS
WE'VE HAD A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
IN. A CALIFORNIA VERSUS A
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED ID. AND
THE REASON FOR THE FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED IDEAS BECAUSE OF THE
ENHANCED IDENTIFICATION- IN ON
AN AUTHENTICATION REQUIREMENTS
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AS WE-
MOVE FROM JUST A CALIFORNIA ID
INTO THE FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED.
SO HOW WOULD THAT PLAY OUT-
WOULD THEY BE USING
AUTHENTICATION DOCUMENTS
THROUGH ONLY A CALIFORNIA ID OR
REQUIRE A FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED.
CALIFORNIA IDEA. HE DIED I. CAN
GIVE YOU BUT WHAT I CAN TELL
YOU THE LEAST BREAK RIGHT NOW
IS OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE TO SHOW
SOME TYPE OF FORM OF ID-
USUALLY THE DRIVER'S LICENSES
JOINED THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
OKAY BUT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
I WOULD DEFINITELY LOOK INTO.
IT AS IT MOVES ALONG YOU
LOOKING AT IT JUST CURIOUS BUT
I'LL BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOU
TODAY. THANK YOU. RIGHT THANK
YOU SIR GORGEOUS. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO OTHER MICROPHONES WAY
IT RAISED- SERVICEMEMBER DAVIES
WE WERE UNABLE TO LOCATE MR
CARE MONDAY. WOULD YOU CARE TO
CLOSE- BUT LET'S SEE IS THERE A
MOTION CENTER JONES MOST OF
BILL- YOU CHECK YOUR CLOTHES SO
NUMBER CERTAINLY- I JUST WANTED
TO KNOW- I HAVE BEEN DEALING
WITH THIS FOR THE LAST YEAR.
I'VE HAD AN EVENT COMPANY FOR
TWENTY ONE YEARS ON THE WEDDING
PLANNER. AND SO THIS LAST YEAR
AND A HALF I'VE BEEN DEALING
WITH THEM YOU KNOW PEOPLE TRY
TO GET MARRIAGE LICENSE. A LOT
OF OUR MILITARY AND HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO GO
AND GET THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOING TO BE SHIPPING OUT IN
REGARDS TO INSURANCE AND THINGS
LIKE THAT I'VE ALSO HAD- EIGHTY
EIGHT. SOME CONCERNS WITH
CERTAIN PEOPLE THAT WEREN'T
ABLE TO GET OUT TO GO GET IT.
AND SO THIS IS ALSO VERY HANDY
SO- I'M HOPING THAT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S JUST ANOTHER
OPTION FOR PEOPLE AND AGAIN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR I'M SURE
THINGS WILL BE LOOKING
DIFFERENT. BUT I CERTAINLY AM
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND SO I ASKED
FOR AN I OR AN IDEA OF. ALL
RIGHT- THANK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IF THE SECURE MONTY SHOWS
UP ON ANOTHER BILL LATER ON
WE'LL LET YOU KNOW. ALL RIGHT-
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION MADAM
CHIEF COUNSEL PLEASE. CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY THREE BY SOME REMEMBERED
DAVIES WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
JOHNSON MOTION IS DO YOU PASS.
UMBERG BY NUMBER GUY BURGESS-
FORGES HI KELLY AT ALL HI ADAM
I. DID I SO I DO. SO I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HERZ BERG. JONES HI
JONES I LAYERED PIE LAYERED I
STERN WHITE HOUSE SKI. HI WAY
CASKEY I WEINER. WE HAVE EIGHT
ZERO SO FAR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
HAVE BEEN TOLD NEVER TO FALL IN
LOVE WITH YOUR BILLS ALTHOUGH I
THINK SENATOR ALSO JUST MARRIED
THIS- AND YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT
I AM MORE DEAN SO I COULD
ACTUALLY MAKE. RIGHT NOW ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
RIGHT THAT WE'RE GONNA PUT THE
BILL ON CALL AND I A. C.
ASSEMLY MEMBER KYLIE IS HERE-
WITH EIGHTY TWO SEVEN TWO.
AFTER WE'RE DONE CLEANING THE
PODIUM. SEVEN MEMBER KYLIE. WE
WELCOME. YOU AND YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
VICE CHAIR THIS BILL. AIMS TO
ASSURE THAT A VICTIM OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT
KURDISH PURSUE A CIVIL ACTION.
AGAINST THE PERPETRATOR AND
OTHER RELEVANT PARTIES- WHAT WE
SOMETIMES SEE IS THAT
ENROLLMENT AGREEMENTS EITHER
SIGNED BY THE PARENT- WILL
CONTAIN ARBITRATION CLAUSE THAT
IS THEN- ENFORCED AGAINST THE
CHILD AFTER. AN INJURY HAS
OCCURRED- NOW THERE ARE MANY
REASONS WHY I POINT IF IN ANY
CASE- WE MIGHT SEE ARBITRATION
AS- A DESIRABLE OPTION IT CAN
BE LESS EXPENSIVE FASTER- MORE
PRIVATE. HOWEVER THERE ARE
SEVERAL REASONS WHY- THOSE
ADVANTAGES DO NOT ALWAYS OBTAIN
IN THE CIRCUMSTANCES. PRESENTED
HERE- FIRST UNLIKE CONTRACTS
FOR SERVICES OR OTHER BUSINESS
VENTURES- EDUCATION IS
SOMETHING THAT IS BOTH A RIGHT
AND IS COMPULSORY THAT. OUR OF
THEIR EDUCATION THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO ATTEND THE SCHOOL.
SECONDLY CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT IS NOT A FORESEEABLE
CIRCUMSTANCE WHEN ROLLING IN
SCHOOL WHEN THE PARENT- SIGNS
THEIR CHILD UP THEY AGREED TO A
NUMBER OF TERMS AND CONDITIONS
RELATING TO SCHOOL HOURS
TUITION DRESS CODE ON THE BIKE
BUT- IT'S- ON THE FORESEEABLE
AT THAT MOMENT. FOR A PARENT TO
BELIEVE THAT A CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT WOULD BE PART OF THE
CHILD'S EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE
AND SO. THIS BILL CLARIFIES
THAT REQUIRING A VICTIM OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT TO GO
TO ARBITRATION IS ON
CONSCIONABLE WHICH IS A
STANDARD- THAT HAS BEEN HAVE
HELD IN THE COURTS EVEN AFTER-
THE LANDMARK CASE ON THE
FEDERAL ARBITRATION ACT. ACT
CONCEPCION- AND THE THIRD
REASON WHY THIS BILL. IS
NECESSARY IS THAT CAL AND IT IS
ALLOWABLE UNDER- THAT PRESIDENT
IS THAT CALIFORNIA LAW IS CLEAR
ON THE DIFFERENCE IN TREATMENT-
AFFORDED TO MINORS. PERTINENT
CASE LAW SUPPORTS THE NOTION
THAT CLAIMS HELD BY CHILDREN I
CAN NOT BE FORCED INTO
ARBITRATION AND CHILDREN HAVE
THE RIGHT. TO DETERMINE ALL
MATTERS THAT CONCERN THEIR OWN
WELFARE ADDITIONALLY FAMILY
CODE SECTION SIXTY SEVEN TEN
PROVIDES THE CONTRACT A MINOR
MAY BE. DECIPHERED BY THAT
MINOR IN THE FEDERAL
ARBITRATION ACT DOES NOT SPEAK
TO THE ISSUE OF A PARENT'S
CAPACITY TO CONTRACTUALLY BIND
A MINOR- WHEN IT COMES TO WITH
THE CHOICE OF FORUM- AS
ARBITRATION. AND THIS IS THERE
FOR AN ISSUE THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS- THREE STATE LEVEL
LEGISLATION FOR THE SAKE OF
FUTURE VICTIMS I THINK THIS IS.
AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION- THE PAST RESTORE-
THE RIGHT OF THESE VICTIMS TO
PURSUE- THEIR CLAIMS AS PART OF
A CIVIL ACTION. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY DAD.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER- I NOTE MR
RICHARD SCHWARTZ AND MISS
REBECCA SCHWARTZ NOT RELATED TO
ONE ANOTHER ARE PRESENT TO
TESTIFY- TELEPHONICALLY IS THAT
CORRECT SOMEONE MEMBER. ALL
RIGHT- MODERATOR IF YOU TWO UP-
MR SCHWARTZ AND MR SCHWARTZ.
BERLIN EUROPEAN- PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND SENATORS AND THANK YOUR
FAMILY MEMBER KYLIE MY NAME IS
RICHARD SCHWARTZ I'M A PARTNER
WITH BROWN YOUR DROP O'BRIEN IN
A WAY AND ALEX AND I HEARD YOU
ON THE BOAT I WAY TO EIGHTY TO
SEVENTY TWO. EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY
TWO WOULD ALLOW INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE THE VICTIMS OF CRIMINAL
SEXUAL ASSAULT OR CRIMINAL
BATTERY IN A SCHOOL CONTACT TO
SEEK JUSTICE THROUGH THE COURT
SYSTEM EVEN IF THE SCHOOLS AND
ROAMING AGREEMENT WOULD
OTHERWISE THAN THAT DUE TO
ARBITRATION. RIGHT NOW
CALIFORNIA LAW AUTHORIZES
SCHOOLS TO FORCE STUDENTS AND
PARENTS TO SIGN NON NEGOTIABLE
AND ENROLLMENT AGREEMENTS THOSE
AGREEMENTS OFTEN HAVE CLAUSES
THAT AMONG OTHER THINGS ALLOW
THOSE SCHOOLS TO HIDE IT
DISAPPEARED BEHIND THE VEIL OF
THE CONFIDENTIAL ARBITRATION
EVEN WHEN A STUDENT HAS CLAIMED
BASED ON PROVEN CRIMINAL.
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT. CORKER CHOIR
REPORTS. THIS PROUD. FOR SCHOOL
CAN. WHO DESPERATELY NEED
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
PROCEDURE THEIR SCHOOLS ARE
TAKING OR FAILING TO TAKE. TO
PREVENT CRIMINAL SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT ON THEIR PREMISES.
EVEN MORE PROBLEMATIC IS THE
IMPACT OF ARBITRATION ON A
VICTIM OF CRIMINAL SEXUAL
ASSAULT. CALIFORNIA LAW MAKES
CLEAR THAT AN ARBITRATOR CAN
DECIDE THE MATTER BEFORE THEM
NOT ON THE BASIS OF THE LAW OR
THE RULES OF EVIDENCE BUT
RATHER SOLELY ON ON B.
AMBIGUOUS NOTIONS OF EQUITY. AS
PERCEIVED BY THAT ARBITRATOR
OFTEN A SINGLE PERSON WITH HIS
OR HER OWN BIAS EVEN
PRECONCEPTIONS. THAT MEANS THAT
AN ARBITRATOR COMPLETELY IGNORE
THE LAW AND PREVENT THE STUDENT
WAS SEXUALLY ASSAULTED FROM
OBTAINING THE JUSTICE. THEY
COULD OBTAIN THROUGH THE COURT.
EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY TWO WOULD
FIX THAT BY STUDENTS TO DEATH
THE FIRM THOUGH THE ROMAN
AGREEMENT AFTER BEING THE
VICTIM OF THE SEXUAL ASSAULT. I
SHOULD EMPHASIZE THAT EIGHTY
TWO SEVENTY TWO HAS A VERY
NARROW SCOPE. ITS PROVISIONS
ARE ONLY TRIGGERED WHEN THERE
IS CRIMINAL SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
THAT FORMED THE BASIS OF THE
STUDENT CLAIMS. CALIFORNIA
CONVICTED LOOPHOLE THAT ALLOWS
SCHOOLS TO EDUCATE THE COURT
THAT THEM AND AVOID THE PUBLIC
RECONCILIATION PRODUCT THAT THE
BEATING UNITIES NEED TO HEAL
AND MOVE ON. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION AND THE
PORTENT BELL WHICH WOULD GO A
LONG WAY TO SECURING JUSTICE
FOR THE VICTIMS OF CHILDHOOD
SEXUAL ASSAULT. NEXT YOU'LL
HEAR FROM MY CLIENT REBECCA
SCHWARTZ WHO CAN TELL YOU THAT
THIS IS NOT SIMPLY AN ACADEMIC
EXERCISE IT HAS REAL WORLD
CONSEQUENCES. AND OTHERS ALL BY
ASKING EACH SENATOR. TO VOTE.
FOR THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THANK YOU MR TOWARDS- MS
REBECCA. SALEABLE YES I AM- THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M HONORED TO SPEAK BEFORE YOU
TODAY THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR A VICTIM'S
PERSPECTIVE. COMING TOWARD MY
FAMILY HAS CHOSEN TO STAND UP
FOR THE SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITY
TO LOWER THE RISK OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN BEING
EXPOSED TO SEXUAL PREDATORS IN
OUR SCHOOL. AMONG THE MANY OF
THE TRUTH WE HAVE LEARNED THAT
MANY WORKING FOR THIS ISSUE IF
YOU NEVER SEE THE LIGHT OF DAY
AND THE CURRENT ARBITRATION
WILL HELP KEEP IT IN THE DARK.
THERE ARE FEW THINGS WORSE THAN
HARMING A CHILD ONE THING IS
PREVENTING THAT SHOP IN SEEKING
JUSTICE FOR THAT HARM SIMPLY
IGNORING THAT IT EVER HAPPENED.
FOUR YEARS AGO OUR CHILD'S
REPEATEDLY AND BRUTALLY RAPED
BY A TEACHER AT BRENTWOOD
SCHOOL LOS ANGELES. NEARLY
EVERY DAY FOR SEVERAL MONTHS.
THE PERPETRATOR WAS CRIMINALLY.
AND SERVED TIME. OUR CHILDHOOD
PERMANENTLY CHANGED DAMAGES
GUARD BY THE FEARS OF A FULL.
ENGLISH COUPLED WITH THE LOG IN
SHOULD HAVE BEEN AND CONTINUE
TO BE CHALLENGING HEIGHTENED BY
THE FACT THAT OUR CHILD NEVER
GOT THE PROVERBIAL DAY IN
COURT. A JURY TRIAL WOULD BE
ONE WAY TO BRING ABOUT A FULL
INVESTIGATION OF THE CRIMES IN
THE SCHOOLS POLICIES PROCEDURES
GUIDELINES GOVERNANCE AND
CULTURE WHICH MAY HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE CRIME. AND
IN DOING SO WOULD FACILITATE
THE HEALING PROCESS FOR A CHILD
INSTEAD THE CIVIL JUSTICE
SYSTEM DO NOT APPLY THE JURY
TRIAL BECAUSE SPRINT WITH
SCHOOL INCLUDED A MANDATORY
CONFIDENTIAL ARBITRATION CLAUSE
IN IT IN WOMAN AGREEMENT. OUR
TRIAL DID NOT SIGN AN AGREEMENT
AND YET WOULD HELP TO IT MY
HUSBAND AND I FIND BELIEVING
THAT MOST ARBITRATION WOULD
COVER GRIEVANCES WE MIGHT HAVE
WITH THE FULL DISCARDING OUR
HEALTH EDUCATION. WE NEVER
ENVISIONED IT WOULD COVER A
VIOLENT FELONY CRIME AND WE
CERTAINLY NEVER ENVISIONED WE
WERE SIGNING AWAY OUR CALLS
RIGHT CHOOSE YOUR OWN PATH
JUSTICE NO PARENT DOES OR
SHOULD. THE COMMON PARENTS TO
SIGN THE AGREEMENT IS THAT
ARBITRATION IS INTENDED TO
RESOLVE ISSUES RELATED TO
ATTENDING A COLLECTIVE
AGREEMENT ABOUT A GREATER
SCHOOL CURRICULUM. ARBITRATION
CERTAINLY HAS ITS PLACE IN THE
CIVIL JUSTICE. BUT A GREAT
VICTIM SHOULD. HAVE THE RIGHT
TO CHOOSE. HI TO OUR- CALL TO
EDGE. SEXUAL THE OF A TRIAL.
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO UNDER. ANY
CHANCE OF TRIGGERING. THE
ACCOUNTABILITY. ARBITRATE
NOTICE BECAUSE- REPORTEDLY
LIMITED DISCOVERY AND
DISCLOSURE AND CANCER FAVOR
INSTITUTIONS IT'S NOT ONLY BAD
FOR THE SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS
BUT ALSO FOR SOCIETY. INSULATE
THE INSTITUTION FOR PUBLIC
SCRUTINY THE DIFFICULT LET ME
HELP YOU TRULY SELF REFLECT AND
MAKE REFORMS NECESSARY TO
PREVENT. CRIME AND PROTECT
FUTURE VICTIMS. ALL OF THOSE
WHO WORK IN A SCHOOL HAVE A
CIGARETTE AND PRESCRIBED LEGAL
DUTY TO PROTECT OUR CHILDREN
THANK. YOU WATSON PICK PLACE IT
LOOKS OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
STEPPING FORWARD- WE'RE GONNA
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON NOW. TO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. SO
I'M SORRY. DID YOU TO ADD ONE
MORE SO. ABOUT TWENTY SECONDS
WORTH. WELL IT WE YOU'VE GONE-
TWO MINUTES AND THIRTY FOUR
SECONDS SO- GO HEAD RIGHT. I'M
SORRY FOR THE- FOR BODY AND I
AND I OULD LIKE TO FINISH WHAT
I WILL GO HEAD TO HEAD. SHE
BUILT HER UNCLE UNINVESTIGATED
THE CONSEQUENCE OF PARENTS
AGREE NOT TO SUE THE SCHOOL FOR
GRADE THE DRESS CODE REGARDLESS
OF AMERICAN ARBITRATION OF
UNLOCKING THE COURT. SHOULD SEX
CRIMES AGAINST SCHOOL CHILDREN
AUTOMATICALLY COVERED BEHIND SO
THE CONFIDENTIAL ARBITRATION.
AS A LIFELONG CITIZENS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE ASK HOW
THAT STRUGGLE WITH THAT UNDER
CURRENT LAW IN IN ROME AND
AGREEMENT SIGNED BY PARENTS AS
REQUIRED CONDITION FOR THE
CHILDREN TO ATTEND SCHOOL CAN
OPERATE THE HIGH TECH CRIMES OR
OTHER HIGH FELONIES. BEHIND
CONFIDENTIAL ARBITRATION WE
IMPLORE YOU TO CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLE BY PASSING AB TWO
SEVEN TWO INTO LAW. THE ONLY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IS THE
PRODUCT OF THE BUREAUCRATIC
ETHICAL BACKING THE MORAL
IMPERATIVE IMPERATIVE IS TO
PREVENT SCHOOLS FROM FORCING
BREAK BECOMES IN ARBITRATION
BASED ON DECEPTIVE AND ROAMING
AGREEMENT. AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME LISTENING.
THANK YOU MISS WARTS ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS HAVE SUPPORTED C. KNOWN
IN THE GALLERY AND SUPPORT-
ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. NOW TURNING
THE PHONE LINES OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE PLEASE
GIVE US YOUR NAME. YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE IN. SUPPORT OF A. B.
TWO SEVEN TWO. PLEASE ON THE
LINE IF YOU ARE AN SUPPORT OF A
TWO. TWO PLEASE ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE DAY FOUR SO. OF A B. TWO
SEVEN TWO. LOOKS LIKE WE DO
HAVE TO IN OUR QUEUE WITH JUST
A MOMENT. IT WILL FIRST GO TO
NUMBER FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES ROBIN IT'S BEEN WITH
THE REMEMBRANCE PROJECT IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. TWO SEVEN TWO.
THANK YOU. YOU WILL MORE IN
QUEUE TO BE JUST A MOMENT. NEXT
WE GO TO NUMBERS SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE LINE SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEY'RE
NOT RESPONDING BUT WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE IN OUR QUEUE NEXT WILL
BE GOING TO NUMBER FORTY FIVE.
LINE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK GREAT OPERA I'M IN SANTA
CLARITA CALIFORNIA I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MODERATE ANYONE
ELSE'S SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT CAN
YOU LET'S TURN THE OPPOSITION-
I HAVE NO WITNESSES AT LEAST NO
MAIN WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE COME THE
MICROPHONE I SEE NO ONE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE RISING IN
OPPOSITION LET'S TURN TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE- WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
SEVEN TWO. THE LADY JOHN
MCCARRON OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
TWO OR IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. WE DO HAVE ONE IN OUR
QUEUE TO BE JUST A MOMENT ALL
RIGHT. WE GO TO NUMBER FIFTY OR
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF RUSSIA WHICH IS
HELPING HIM A COMMERCE
APOLOGIES FOR THE CONFUSION I
INTENDED TO BUY THE PRINCIPAL
OPPOSITION BUT WAS SLOW IN
CONTACTING STAFF. CALLED IT IF
THAT WOULD ELP WITH THE LEAVE
THE CHAIR I'LL KEEP MY REMARKS
BRIEF BUT I JUST LIKE YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES JUST TO MAKE. SURE
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES THANK YOU
VERY- THEY GET WRONG SHOULD
HELP ME CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE
ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO A.
B. TWO SEVENTY TWO. TO BE CLEAR
OPPOSITION IS NOT. RELATED TO
SEXUAL ASSAULT WE IN NO WAY
CONDONE THAT TERRIBLE THING- IT
HAPPENED- TO THE TO THE- FAMILY
WHICH WAS JUST TEST PLAN THERE.
ARE HUGE. MEAT SIMPLY FOCUSED
ON- THE FEDERAL LEGALITY OF
THIS LET ARBITRATION- SIMPLY
PUT- THE AT. THIS TIME OKAY
THIS MATTER SUPREME COURT TO
TWENTY ELEVEN EIGHTEEN TEAM
ABILITY CONCEPCION- PRECLUDE
THIS BILL THE COURT SPOKE QUITE
CLEARLY THERE. AND I QUOTE. THE
FAA- PERMIT OUR AGREEMENT TO
ARBITRATE TO BE INVALIDATED BY
GENERALLY APPLICABLE CONTRACT
OFFENSES SUCH AS FRAUD TO
RESTAURANT CONTABILIDADE. BUT
NOT BY DEFENSE DID THAT APPLY
ONLY TO ARBITRATION. OR DERIVE
THEIR MEANING TO THE FACT THAT
AN AGREEMENT TO ARBITRATE IF
THAT ISSUE- AND THAT IN FACT
THERE IS THREE THIRTY NINE- WE
THINK THIS BILL FALLS SQUARELY
INTO THAT THIS IS A BILL WHICH-
IS. DESIGNED AS- AN EXCEPTION
TO ARBITRATION IN A LETTER TO
CONTACT THE JUST ABOUT
ARBITRATION. YOU CAN WAIVE AN
AGREEMENT TO ARBITRATE IN THAT
CONTEXT NOT CREATING A
GENERALLY APPLICABLE DEFENSE TO
OTHER CONTRACTS SURE FOR THAT
REASON WE BOUGHT I THINK IT'S
CALLED THE TYPICALLY HERE. AND
THEREFORE WILL BE PRESENTED
WITH A SIMILAR TO HOWEVER
WEBBER'S TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN
OF TWENTY FOURTEEN TO PRINT
WHICH CREATED A SIMILAR-
INDIVIDUAL DEFENSE DOCTORS
AGREEMENT AND WAS STRUCK DOWN
BY CALIFORNIA COURTS- I'LL KEEP
IT BRIEF AND STOP THERE SO.
THAT IS OUR CONCERN IS. GREAT
THE PREEMPTION ISSUE AND NOT TO
THE SEXUAL. ASSAULT ISSUE.
THANK OPPOSED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OUR UP IT BACK TO THE
CHAIN ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITE
MR MOTT ON THE PHONE LINE THAT
THAT THIS THERE ARE NOOTHERS
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE TALK ALL
RIGHT- LOOKING FOR THE CHAMBER
I SEE NO WHO'S- IS- IS THERE A
MOTION. THE CENTER BOARD
DISPOSABLE. ALL RIGHT- SOONER
KYLIE WOULD YOU CARE TO CLOSE.
I THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS
CONSIDERATION AND I'D ASK FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER
CHI NOTED THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS. ARE ONCE
AGAIN ALIGNED WITH THE SIMPLY
MEMBER KYLIE. THIS IS THIS IS A
YOU KNOW SORT OF AN UNUSUAL
COMBINATION I UNDERSTAND
ANYWAY- HAVING SAID THAT MADAM
CHIEF COUNSEL TO CALL THE ROLL.
YES THIS IS A B. TWO SEVENTY
TWO BY A FAMILY MEMBER HEY LEE
WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
BORJA SENATORS COULD YOU ADD
SPEAK INTO YOUR MICROPHONE WHEN
YOU- POST THANK YOU. AMBERG I'M
SORRY THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AMBERG HI. AMBERG HI FORGES I
WOULD JUST I CARRY IT ON I HAVE
YET- I DID ALSO. THE TEST SO.
HI BEGIN TO MICROPHONE SORRY.
HI DID I SO I CONSULATES HIGH
GONZALEZ HI HURTS BURKE JONES
HI JONES I LAYERED LAYERED ICE
STERN WHITE HOUSE SKIING I'D
WAKE COUNTY I WINNER. YOU HAVE
EIGHT ZERO SO FAR ALL RIGHT-
THANK YOU SOOOO OR KYLIE WILL
PUT THIS ON CALL NEXT WE HAVE A
SEVEN MEMBER BENNETT.
ALL RIGHT.
SEVEN MEMBER BENNETT. EIGHTY
EIGHT SIX ONE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON TO
YOU AND TO THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HERE TODAY. TWO EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY ONE A-
I BELIEVE THE FOCUS OF SHOULD
BE ONE SIMPLE POINT AND THAT IS
ABOUT 30% OF MOBILE HOMES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE COVERED UNDER
LOCAL RENT CONTROL LAWS THOSE
LOCAL RECKONED WITH TROLL LAWS
HAVE BEEN VALIDATED OVER AND
OVER AGAIN BY THE COURTS ON THE
BASIS THAT WE NEED THAT LAW TO
PROTECT THE EQUITY INVESTMENT.
THAT THE PARK OWNER HAS IN
THEIR MOBILE HOME. IF PARK
OWNERS PURCHASE THE MOBILE
HOMES IN THEIR PARK THEY PULL
THOSE UNITS HELP FROM LOCAL
RENT CONTROL ORDINANCES AND
THUS REDUCE THE STOCK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
COMMUNITY. I HAVE OVER EIGHT
THOUSAND MOBILE HOMES IN MY
DISTRICT AND MANY OF THEM ARE
COVERED BY LOCAL RENT CONTROL
LAWS. THE MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY
LAW THAT WAS PASSED IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES IDENTIFIED
THAT PARK OWNERS NEEDED TO
APPLY THE SAME RULES TO
THEMSELVES THAT THEY APPLY TO
THEIR PARK RESIDENTS. MY GOAL
WITH THIS BILL IS JUST SIMPLY
MAKE SURE THAT THAT LAW IS
ENFORCED. BECAUSE THAT'S THE
BEST WAY TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T
CREATE AN INCENTIVE FOR
CREATING AN OUTPOST CONSENT FOR
ANY LONGER FOR PARK OWNERS TO
PURCHASE THESE. MOBILE HOMES
AND TAKE THEM OUT OF THE LOCAL
RENT CONTROL AND THEREFORE OUT
OF THE STOCK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. MY GOAL IS NOT TO
TRY TO FIND A WAY FOR ALL OF
THE PARK RESIDENTS TO START
RENTING OUT THEIR MOBILE HOMES
AND I THINK. IT'S NOT REALISTIC
TO THINK THAT MOST PEOPLE WOULD
WANT TO DO THAT IF THEY LIVE IN
A MOBILE HOME AND THEY ARE
COVERED UNDER RENT CONTROL.
WHAT THEY MOST WANT IS
STABILITY AND THEY WANT
STABILITY TO KNOW THAT THEY
WILL BE LIVING WITH LIKE MINDED
NEIGHBORS COVERED BY THE SAME.
RECORD LOCAL RENT CONTROL LAW
AND SO CONSEQUENTLY I THINK
WHAT THIS. DOESN'T DO AS MANY
OF THE SCENARIOS THAT HAVE BEEN
LAID OUT BY THE OPPONENTS OF
THIS BILL WHICH IS CREATE
TERRIBLE SITUATIONS WHERE
THERE'LL BE ALL KINDS OF
PRINTING ETCETERA. AND I MIGHT
POINT OUT THAT I THINK THE
STAFF ANALYSIS THAT WAS
PRESENTED TO YOU AND THIS HAS
BEEN OUTSTANDING AND THAT STAFF
ANALYSIS VERY CLEARLY POINTS
OUT A NUMBER ONE THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OPINION WAS
VERY CLEAR. NOW THAT THE
OPPONENTS ARE PICKING AND
CHOOSING- AND THEN ALSO
OFFERING SOME VERY ODD.
ANTIDOTE ALL PIECES OF EVIDENCE
TO SUGGEST THAT THERE'S GOING
TO BE A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IN
TERMS OF LEASING AND SUB
LEASING AND RENTING OUT OF
THEIR SPACES. IN REALITY THE
FINAL THING. I'D LIKE TO LEAVE
WITH YOU IS SIMPLY THIS. IF
OWNERS DON'T TO RE. TO OUT
THEIR MO HOMES. AND I THINK
THAT'S GREAT. AS I LIKE TO KEEP
THE LOCAL RECORD TROLL ALL
THERE AND KEEP THE CURRENT
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE. ALL THEY
HAVE TO DO IS MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S THE RULE AND THEN THEY
NEED TO FOLLOW IT ALSO. BUT IF
THEY FOLLOW THAT RULE. AND
FRIEND THIS BILL CLARIFIES
WHAT. WAS IN THE LANGUAGE BACK
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND
THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL HARRIS-
CLARIFIED IN HER. OPINION IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN. THEN WE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO BOTH KEEP
THE STATUS QUO AND TAKE AWAY AN
INCENTIVE FOR PARK OWNERS TO
PURCHASE HOMES TO MOVE THEM OUT
OF LOCAL RENT CONTROL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU SOME
MEMBER BENNETT I UNDERSTAND
THAT MISTER BRUCE STANTON IS ON
THE PHONE LINE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. IS THAT RIGHT
MODERATOR. YES I O SHOW THEIR
CONNECTED- I USE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THANK YOU YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES WAS JUST THANK YOU GET
IT GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS BRUCE STANTON GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR GSM- WELL. WORK
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS ARE AN
EQUALLY TREATED WHEN IT COMES
TO THE ABILITY TO RENT OR
SUBLEASE THEIR HOMES WHILE MOST
PARKS. HAVE RULES PROHIBITING
RESIDENTS FROM REGULAR SUB
LEASING WHICH THE LAW ALLOWS.
THOSE SAME PARKS OFTEN PURCHASE
AND RENT OUT OR SELL PLEASE
MOBILE HOMES OWNED BY PARK
MANAGEMENT AND THIS RESULTS. IN
AN UNFAIR SITUATION WHERE THE
PARK OWNER IS NOT FOLLOWING ITS
OWN RULES. AND GET THE BENEFIT
OF SELF POLICING BALLPARK
RESIDENTS DO NOT. THE TWENTY
THIRTEEN ATTORNEY GENERAL
OPINION DECLARED THAT BASED
UPON THE EXISTING MOBILE HOME
RESIDENCY LAW. PARK RULES APPLY
EQUALLY TO MANAGEMENT RESIDENTS
AT A PARK OWNER IS ALSO BOUND
TO FOLLOW ITS OWN RULES
PROHIBITING SELF POLICING. BUT
PARK OWNERS HAVE TRIED TO
DISTINGUISH THE AG OPINION
BIKES AND THAT THE RULE
PROHIBITING. RESIDENTS FROM SO
POLICING DOES NOT APPLY TO THEM
SINCE THEY OWN THE HOMES AND
THEY'RE DIRECTLY RENTING THEM.
THIS IS REALLY THOUGH A
DISTINCTION WITHOUT A
DIFFERENCE BECAUSE WHETHER YOU
CALL IT A RENTAL OR IT'S SO
PLEASE THE END RESULT IS THE
SAME. RESIDENTS CAN'T SO PLEASE.
PARK MANAGEMENT SHOULD BE
EQUALLY BOUND IT SHOULD ABIDE
BY THEIR OWN RULES. THE MRO
SHOULD BE AMENDED TO
SPECIFICALLY ELIMINATE THIS
DOUBLE STANDARD. THE FINAL KEY
POINTS FIRST THE BILL DOES NOT
IMPEDE A PARK OWNERS ABILITY TO
CREATE OR CHANGE ITS RULES IF
IT WISHES TO PATTERNS OF
LEASING A RENTING. IT CONTINUES
TO HAVE UNILATERAL ABILITY TO
DO THAT. OR IF YOU WISH TO
ALLOW SUBLEASE KERENSKY WE
COULD DO THAT TOO. SECONDLY THE
BILL DOES NOT PREVENT THE PARK
FROM HOUSING THEIR EMPLOYEES
AND RECENT ADVANCEMENTS HAVE
EVEN EXPANDED AND CLARIFIED
THAT POINT EACH. THE BILL
SIMPLY CLARIFIES THAT WANTS TO
PARK ON A BENCH AT THE STATION
TO ALLOW OR PROHIBIT SEPT WE
SEEK A RANKING. EVERYONE
INCLUDING THE PARK OWNER WOULD
ABIDE BY AND FOLLOW THE SAME
RULES. SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU.
TAKING A STAND. OF OTHERS IN
SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE NO
ONE. ON THE PHONE LINE
MODERATOR OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
THE PHONE LINE. IN THE GERMAN
OCCURRED SUPPORT OF THE V.
EIGHT SIX ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE
ZERO FOR SUPPORT. WE DEVELOP-
THE CASHIER WAS SEVEN IN OUR
QUEUE IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT.
ALL RIGHT FOR THOSE IN Q. IF
YOU'D STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT. L. SERVER
NUMBER FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS MERRY
GO THERE A KITCHEN I DIDN'T
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND I SUPPORT
THE BILL SIXTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT TO NUMBER FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARK
O'CONNELL SAN JOSE WHERE WE
HAVE FIFTY NINE PARK I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU. TEXAS
NUMBER SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MICHELLE MOANING I LIVE
IN A MOBILE HOME PARK IN
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THE B. EIGHT SIXTY ONE.
THANK YOU. WELL NOW GO TO LINE
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS BOBBY MAGNETS AND I
LIVE IN THE CITY OF ORANGE. AND
PARKOUR L. MOBILE HOME PARK AND
WE SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY
ONE THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JUDY WOULD
HAVE WORKED I AM THE FOUNDER OF
THE SUNNYVALE MOBILE HOME PARK
ALLIANCE LOCATED IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA. WE HAVE
TWELVE PARKS OF THE POPULATION
OF ELEVEN THOUSAND AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT IT S. B. EIGHT
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU. NEXT UP
IS NUMBER TWENTY TWO HE'S GOOD
AT. MY NAME IS AMAN DOLL I AM A
MOBILE HOME OWNER IN THE CITY
OF LONG BEACH IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SIXTY
ONE ALONG WITH MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED OF MY FELLOW RESIDENTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
THE EX IS FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
WHO'S OUR SKI I LIVE IN FREMONT
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA MY
MOBILE HOME PARK HAS TWO
HUNDRED. THIRTY FIVE HOUSEHOLDS
AND I STRONLY SUPPORT A. B.
EIGHT SIX ONE THANK YOU. NOW GO
TO NUMBER FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS LESLIE WESTBROOK I LIVE IN
CARPINTERIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT TO
THE NUMBER SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI I'M ELIZABETH
THANK YOU EVEN RANCHER YELLOW
IN DAVIS CALIFORNIA I REPRESENT
THREE MEN AND FIFTY RESIDENTS
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT-
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY ONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
FOR SUPPORT PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT LET'S TURN NOW TO
OPPOSITION TO A. B. EIGHT SIX
ONE- IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GO AHEAD I SEE ONE
WITNESS DEPOSITION- THAT'S NOT
MR GOVERNOR BUT GO AHEAD. NO MR
GOVERNORS MUCH BETTER LOOKING.
THAN GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRIS
WYSOCKI ON BEHALF OF W. AND
MAY. AND WMA MUST RESPECTFULLY
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT OPPOSE AB
SIXTY ONE. WE ESSENTIALLY
DISAGREE WITH THE PREMISE OF
COMPARING RENTING HOMES TO SELF
POLICING. WE WANT TO ALSO THANK
THE CONSULTANT TIM GRIFFITHS
FOR HIS TIME AND WORK ON THE
BILL IT'S BEEN MUCH APPRECIATED
AND HE'S PROBABLY SPENT WAY TOO
MUCH TIME WITH US ACCORDING TO
HIM. WMA POSES THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE OWNERS ACTUALLY HAVE A
CONTRACT WITH THE RESIDENT WHO
OWNS THE HOME. I CERTAINLY SEE
DOESN'T HAVE A CONTRACT WITH
THE OWNER OF THE PARK AND MOST
OFTEN DOESN'T HAVE A CONTRACT
WITH THE RESIDENT OWNER EITHER.
THAT'S WHY WE DON'T BELIEVE
SEVEN LEASING AND RENTING OR
THE SAME CONCEPT. THERE'S ALSO
NO DEFINING OF WHAT A SHORT
TERM RENTAL IS IN THIS BILL.
CONNORS RAN T. THEIR MONTH TO
MONTH. OR ON AN ANNUAL YEAR
BASIS. NOTHING IN THIS BILL
PREVENTS ANYONE FROM RUNNING
EVERY WEEK. W. M. A. BELIEVES
IT SHOULD BE AT LEAST LANGUAGE.
LIMITING SEVENTY SEEM TO NO
LESS THAN THIRTY DAYS. FINALLY
IF SOMEONE'S LEASING SUB
LEASING A HOME FOR SIX MONTHS
OR A YEAR. IN DOING IT
ANNUALLY. WHY ARE THEY GETTING%
THE BENEFIT OF RENT CONTROL.
SHOULD SOMEBODY ELSE BE GETTING
THAT BENEFIT SOMEBODY THAT
ACTUALLY NEEDS TO NEEDS TO HELP.
THE STATE SHOULD WANT PEOPLE TO
MOVE OUT SO THAT SOMEBODY THAT
NEEDS DIRECT CONTROL SPACE GETS.
FOR THESE REASONS WMA DOESN'T
BELIEVE SO POLICING IS GOOD
POLICY FOR HOUSING. ESPECIALLY
IN RING CONTROLLED AREAS AND WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY CONTINUES TO
OPPOSE THIS MEASURE THANK YOU
THANKS SIR. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE ROOM ONE TWELVE NO ONE
ELSE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
OPPOSITION LET'S TURN TO THE
PHONE LINES. MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO.
A. B. EIGHT SIX ONE. AND LATER
ON IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
A V. EIGHT SIX ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE ZERO
OUR POSITION. MISTER CHAIR I
APOLOGIZE FOR INTERRUPTING THE
STATION I COULD HEAR I WAS
ASSIGNED AS A PRIMARY WITNESS
AN OPPOSITION I'M HAPPY TO GIVE
MY TESTIMONY IF IT'S
APPROPRIATE NOW ALL RIGHT GO
AHEAD. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AGAIN J.
SNYDER WITH ADULTS CAN GO OVER
ROPES AND SMITH ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS ALLIANCE- REGRETTABLY I
CONTINUE TO BE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL IS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED- BYE BYE COMMITTEE
TODAY- BUT DO WANT TO ECHO
MISTER WYSOCKI DEPRECIATION FOR
YOUR STAFF'S TIME AND ATTENTION
OF THE BELL AND EDIT KNOWLEDGE
THAT. ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WE HAD RABIES RELATED TO
UNCLEAR LANGUAGE IN THE BILL ON
DESIGNATION TENETS OF THEM
PLAYS HAS BEEN ADDRESSED.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS THERE
ANY NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT STILL
REMAIN- AS ADAM WITH THAT. GOT
MR MIGHT TALKING NOTED. THERE
IS AN ISSUE RELATED TO
APPLICATION OF RENT CONTROL-
THE BILL IS SILENT- AND WE
BELIEVE CPA BELIEVES THAT THAT
THAT WHERE. THE MENTAL PART
COMING HOME IS SUBJECT TO RENT
CONTROL RENTAL OF THE- OF THE
RESIDENT HOME HOME SHOULD ALSO
BE SUBJECT TO RENT CONTROL- AND-
SPECIALLY RELEVANT IN LIGHT OF
THE FACT THAT THE YOUR
COMMITTEE WILL BE CONSIDERING A
BILL NEXT WEEK EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD
SUBJECT. APARTMENT HOMES
STATEWIDE DIRECT CONTROL. NEXT
WHAT WE APPRECIATE AGAIN THE
COMMITTEE AND DIRECTING SOME OF
THE CONCERNS WE HAVE RELATED TO
HOUSING FOR EMPLOYEES. WE
BELIEVE THE PROPOSED RATIO IN
THE BILL OF ONE EMPLOYEE HOME
FOR EVERY TWO HUNDRED HOMES IN
A PARK. MAY NOT BE APPROPRIATE
MAY NOT CAPTURE THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES THAT FOR ALL PARTS OF
IN PARTICULAR LARGER PARTS AND
WE HAD SUGGESTED. ONE EMPLOYEE
HOME FOR EVERY- ONE HUNDRED
HOMES IN A PARK. THE BILL ALSO
DOESN'T HAVE A MECHANISM FOR
THOSE PARKS THAT IT. ACTED AT
TEN SIXTY ONE WERE TO PASS.
WHICH WOULD DISCONTINUE RENTAL
OF BOTH PARK AND READ THEIR OWN
HOMES GOING FORWARD TERE'S NO
REAL PROCESS. TO WIND DOWN
THOSE TENDENCIES- AND LASTLY.
IN THE EVENT. OF THE NEED FOR
SIGNIFICANT REHABILITATIVE WORK
IN A PARK AND REALLY THINK
EVENTS LIKE- A WILD FIRE AND
EARTHQUAKE. THERE'S NO-
EXCEPTION IN. THIS BILL OR OR
NO MEANS ALLOWING WORKERS AND
EMPLOY TO BE. IN THE PARK OF
THAT WORK THAT IS TAKEN ON. SO
ONCE. WITH WITH THE REMAIN WE
MUSTER OPPOSED TO THE BILL
RESPECT REQUEST YOU KNOW. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT- LET IF I HAD A
USE MEMBER THE U. X. THE MEMBER
PROPOSED ON PAGE. COMMENTS SO
NOW YES I DO ALL RIGHT AFTER
THE STAFF. OUR OTHERS IT UP AS-
ON THE PHONE. ANYONE ELSE IN
OUR POSITION ON THE PHONE WE
DO A VOTE FOR IN OUR QUEUE ALL
RIGHT IF YOU'D STATE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION. ALL STAR NUMBER SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CREAM THREE C. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS KEITH FRIEDMAN. FOR THE PAST
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS MY WIFE AND
I HAVE OWNED AND OPERATED THE
SUN RISES MANUFACTURED HOME
COMMUNITY IN CITRUS HEIGHTS
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA. WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. EIGHT
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT TO THE NUMBER SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DURATION AT
AND- PARKED ON A BEACH WITH
PARKING VILLAGE AMONG OTHERS
OPPOSE THE BILL IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE TO FIX UP TENANTS OF
THE TENANT YOU'RE UNABLE TO. RT
THANK YOU. NEXT TO THE NUMBER
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS ROBIN BUT STAN
AND UNLESS FURTHER AMENDED I
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU. AT
THE TIME THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN
OUR QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT LET'S BRING BACK THE
CHAMBER QUESTIONS COMMENTS I
SEE NO MICROPHONES RAISED
CENTER LAYERED MOVES THE BILL
NO SENATOR LETTERHEAD AS
MICROPHONES THAT ARE LAYERED
HIS MICROPHONE UP ALL RIGHT
CENTER LAYERED WITH YOUR
MICROPHONE UP THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT- I
WANTED TO JUST SPEAK FOR A
MOMENT TO THIS BILL BECAUSE I
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH SOME OF
THE MEMBERS BEFORE HAND TO AND
IT SOUNDED LIKE THERE WAS AT
LEAST ONE THAT DOES NOT HAVE
APPRECIABLE. MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS IN THE SENATE
DISTRICT AND WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY I WORK WITH THE
REALTORS AND DID A NUMBER OF
CONSUMER PROTECTION BILLS
RELATED TO MOBILE HOME PARKS
AND I THINK THERE IS A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE I KNOW
THIS IS BASIC TO EVERYBODY BUT
BETWEEN THE COSTA HAWKINS
STANDARD RENT CONTROL FOR
SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENCES AND
SUCH THAT WAS ADOPTED IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES AND MOBILE
HOME RENT CONTROL BECAUSE
MOBILE HOME OWNERS ARE HOSTAGES
THEY DO NOT OWN THE LAND THAT
IS UNDERNEATH THEIR MOBILE HOME
AND IF THERE IS AN EXCESSIVE
RATE INCREASE. FOR THE SPACE OF
THAT THEIR MOBILE HOMES ON AND
THEY OWN THE MOBILE HOME OR
THEY DON'T HAVE THE BUILDING
MANY TIMES TO MOVE IT THEY'RE
AT THE MERCY SO THERE HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED MOBILE HOME RENT
CONTROL AND THIS BILL ADDRESSES
THE LOCALS THAT SERVE A RENT
CONTROL THAT SURVIVE. THAT
GUARANTEES A RATE OF RETURN
THAT CAN BE UNDERSTOOD BY THE
PARK OWNER END GUARANTEES A
RATE OF RENT INCREASES FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE MOBILE HOME
OWNERS IN MANY CASES ARE
SENIORS AND PEOPLE ON FIXED
INCOMES SO THIS IS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN A STATE WHERE THERE
ARE INCREDIBLE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CHALLENGES AND WHAT
THIS BILL IS ATTEMPTING TO
ADDRESS AND MAYBE THEY'RE STILL
AMENDMENTS. THAT NEED TO BE
DONE ON CERTAIN PARTS OF THIS.
BUT THIS BILL A TO THE- FROM
RENT CONTROL OF SOME OF THESE
MOBILE HOMES AND I THINK IT IS.
OF NEEDED JUST GIVEN WHAT WE
FACE WITH REGARD TO HOUSING IN
THE STATE AND I THINK THE
AUTHOR IS COMING DIRECTLY OUT
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
DIRECTLY EXPERIENCED AT THIS IN
HIS PREVIOUS INCARNATION. AND
IS BRINGING SOMETHING THAT HE
SAW NEEDED TO BE ADDRESSED TO
THE LEGISLATURE WITH THIS BILL.
SO I THINK IT'S STRONGLY WORTHY
OF OUR SUPPORT TO AND I'M GOING
TO BE READY TO MOVE IT AND VOTE
FOR IT WHENEVER THERE'S AN
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT. CENTER
LATER THIS IS THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I MOVED HE MOVES THE BILL
ALL RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE. SO
REMEMBER BENNETT YOU CAN CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO CHEER.
THIS BILL WOULD MOVE THROUGH
THE ASSEMBLY IN THE COMMITTEE
AT- DID VERY WELL WHEN IT GOT
TO THE FLOOR THERE WAS QUITE A
BIT OF CONFUSION SO I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO CLARIFY. A COUPLE
OF QUICK POINTS. FROM THE
LANGUAGE OF THE OF THE SENATE
STAFF AND THAT IS WELL THE
PLAIN LANGUAGE APPEARS TO
SUGGEST OTHERWISE AND THAT'S
THE PLAIN LANGUAGE OF THE
NINETEEN NINETY THREE AT THE
FOOT OF SECTION SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT OF THE NINETEEN NINETY
pRENT TO UNLOCK SOME PARKS
APPARENTLY INSIST THE SECTION
SEVEN NINETY EIGHT DOES NOT
PREVENT THEM FROM RENTING OUT
THEIR MOBILE HOMES THAT THEY
OWN. EVEN THE EVEN AS THEY
DENIED THE SAME POSSIBILITY TO
PARK RESIDENTS AND THEN AGAIN
LATER IT SAYS THIS BILL IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD CODIFICATION.
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
CONCLUSION. AND THEN FINALLY IT
SAYS THE OPPONENTS
CORRESPONDENTS MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT IN SPITE OF THE PLAIN
LANGUAGE OF CIVIL CODE SEVEN
NINETY EIGHT. AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OPINION INTERPRETING
IT THEY DO NOT FULLY ACCEPT THE
PARKS MUST COMPLY WITH THE
RULES SAY PROBABLY GREAT
AGAINST RUNNING AND SUB LEASING
TO THE SAME EXTENT BECAUSE OUR
RESIDENTS AND THE RESIDENTS
CAST. AND I THINK MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY IN MY LAST
SENTENCE PULLING FRAGMENTS OUT
OF THE OPINION THE OPPONENTS
CONTEND THAT THE OPINION
SOMEHOW SUPPORTS THE OPPOSITE
CONCLUSION. SO WHEN YOU HAVE
OPPONENTS STAND UP AND SAY THE
BILL DOESN'T HAVE A PROPER
LANGUAGE TO HANDLE- SHORT TERM
RENTALS IN ONE WEEK RENTALS-
AND YET YOU HEAR THAT. THE PARK
OWNERS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ESTABLISH THOSE RULES. ANYWAY
THAT THEY WANT JUST AS LONG AS
THEY FOLLOW THE SAME RULES SO
WHEN THEY RAISE THE SHOP IS THE
THESE ARGUMENTS I HOPE WE COULD
REMEMBER THAT THEY CAN
ESTABLISH THE RULES FOR THEIR
PARKS. THIS BILL SIMPLY REMINDS
THEM THAT AS IT HAS BEEN THE
LAW THEY NEED TO FOLLOW THE
SAME RULES OF THE ESTABLISHMENT
REBAJAS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO IN MEMBER BENNETT
AND CHIEF COUNSEL RECALL ROLE.
THIS IS A V. EIGHT SIX ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT- WITH A
MOTION BY SENATOR WHERE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
UMBERG HI. AMBERG I'D PORGES.
PORGES. NOT VOTING. CARRY IT
OUT I HAVE A AT ALL I DID I SAW.
DID I SO I GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ
HI HERTZBERG JONES NO. JONES
DON'T KNOW LAYERED BY LAYERED I
STERN WHITE HOUSE SKI HI WHY
CASKEY I WINNER WINNER I. YOU
HAVE SEVEN TO ONE SO FAR ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PLACE IT ON CALL
NEXT I SEE SOME REMEMBER S.
BEEN PATIENTLY WAITING SOME OF
THE RACE AND SO THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE LISTENING ARE AWARE-
WILL NEXT YEAR AB NINE HUNDRED
BY SENATOR RAYOS THEN A. B. ONE
ZERO NINE SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOSE THREE OF US- AND THEN WE
WILL CONCLUDE OUR BUSINESS FOR
THE DAY. SO SOME REMEMBER RAYOS
CLOSURES THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE I
PRESENT TO YOU AB NINE HUNDRED
THAT WHICH WOULD REQUIRE A
TRUSTEE OF A TRUST A CHARITABLE
TRUSTTO PROVIDE NOTICE TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WITH THE
CHARITABLE TRUSTEE INTENDS TO
SELL OR TRANSFER ALL OR
SUBSTANTIALLY ALL CHARITABLE
ASSETS OWNED BY THE TRUST.
UNDER EXISTING LAWS NONPROFIT
PUBLIC BENEFIT CORPORATIONS ARE
REQUIRED TO GIVE NO WRITTEN
NOTICE TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHEN THE CORPORATION INTENDS TO
SELL OR TRANSFER ALL OR
SUBSTANTIALLY ALL OF ITS ASSETS
HOWEVER DUE TO AN EXISTING
INCONSISTENCY WITHIN CALIFORNIA
LAW. A CHARITABLE TRUST
CHARITABLE TRUSTS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO GIVE THE AG THIS
SIMPLE NOTICE THAT NONPROFIT
BENEFIT CORPORATIONS ARE
ALREADY REQUIRED TO PROVIDE.
EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED A SIMPLY
FIXES THIS INCONSISTENCY AND
CURRENT LAW AND ENSURES THAT
TRUSTEES ARE ACTING IN GOOD
FAITH. I AM CURRENTLY IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE BANKERS
ASSOCIATION TO FIND SOLUTIONS
TO ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS. HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE R. JOSEPH IS SIMMERING
AND ANTHONY LIU TO DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S WITHIN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS. THANK YOU
VISIT MERMAN- MISTERS IN RING
ARE YOU AVAILABLE. FOR MISTER
LIU HI HI THIS IS ANTHONY LEE-
I'LL GO FOR IT AND JUSTICE
WELCOME BACK AND- MY NAME
DEFINITELY DO AND WITH THE
OFFICE OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
FOR ATTORNEY GENERAL BONDI WE
WANT TO. THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING. EIGHTY NINE
HUNDRED AT THE REQUEST OF OUR
OFFICE. IMAGE THE DISCREPANCY
IN THE LOBBY TO CHARITABLE
TRUST AND PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATION. THAT VERY QUICKLY
THE BILL SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT
CHARITABLE TRUST THE COVERED BY
THE SAME NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
THE AG ALREADY APPLIED THE
PUBLIC BENEFIT CORPORATIONS
WHEN THEY THINK THE TELLER
TRANSFER- LIKE THE THING IS MY
FATHER ASKED THAT THE NOTICE TO
THE AG REQUIRED BY THE BILL.
THAT WILL HELP LIMIT THE
POSSIBILITY OF DEALING IN SUCH
TRANSACTIONS AND HELP ENSURE
THAT THE TRANSACTION IS IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE CHARITABLE
TRUST. AND THE TRUSTEE THE ACT
YOU CAN GOOD SAYING THAT WE'VE
BEEN ADVISING THE OTHER TOPICS
AND PARTICIPATING AND I'M GOING
TO DISCUSSIONS WITH THE BANKERS
ABOUT THEIR CONCERNS. I THINK
THE CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN
PRODUCTIVE AND WE'RE COMMITTED
TO IT AT THE TOP THERE. IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE BANKERS
BEHIND RESOLUTION. AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD. BUT YOU AND I'LL
IT OVER TO. DEPUTY JUMPED ARE.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS. DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL JOE
THE MERINGUE I'M A MEMBER OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL CHARITABLE
TRUSTS SECTION AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHERS IN SUPPORT I SEE NO ONE
IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO ONE
ROOM ONE TWELVE OTHERS A
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINE.
MODERATE IF YOU CHOOSE THOSE IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINE UP.
LATER JOHN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME AGAIN THE CURRENT
SUPPORT OF AB NINE HUNDRED
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE DO
HAVE ONE IN OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR OVER AGAIN MEMBERS
FIFTEEN MOCK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT IN. PORT
EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU MISS MARK ALL
RIGHT ANYONE ELSE. ALL RIGHT AT
THE TIME WE HAVE NO OTHER THAN
Q. PLEASE CONTINUE- IN
OPPOSITION I KNOW THAT WE HAVE
MISTER KEVIN GOULD FROM
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE ON THE
PHONE LINE MISTER GOULD PLEASE
PROCEED. MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS KEVIN GOLD WITH
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE CURRENTLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED.
WE ANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR FOR ENGAGING NOTHING
DIALOGUE OVER THE NET. WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSIONS AND
WE REMAIN HOPEFUL. THAT WE CAN
REACH A COMPROMISE. WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED TO THE UNDERLYING
OBJECTIVE OF THE MEASURE WE
UNDERSTAND THE BEHAVIORS THAT
THE MEASURE INTENDS TO PREVENT
WHICH- BASED ON EXPERIENCES
SHARED WITH US APPEAR TO
INVOLVE THE INDIVIDUAL TRUSTEES
AND NOT CORPORATE TRUSTEES.
TOWARD UNDERSCORING THE BANKS
WOULD TRUST DEPARTMENT OR
SUBJECT TO REGULATORY OVERSIGHT
SUPERVISION AND ROUTINE
EXAMINATION. OUR FOCUS HERE
HERE AT THE HELP CORPORATE
TRUSTEES COMPLY WITH THE LAW
OUR PRIMARY CONCERN WITH THE
MEASURE IS THE LACK OF
DEFINITION FOR SUBSTANTIALLY
ALL. AND WHILE WE UNDERSTAND
POTENTIALLY ONLY BE USED
ELSEWHERE IN THE CALIFORNIA
CODE. IS UNDEFINED USAGE
ELSEWHERE FAILED TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE FOR TRUSTEES WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO UNDERSTAND. WHAT
THE STANLEY ALL MEANS. AND WILL
NEED TO KNOW WHEN THEIRLEGAL
OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE NOTICE
ARRIVES. WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
TURNING GENERAL'S OFFICE
INFORMALLY ADVISED NONPROFIT
PUBLIC BENEFIT CORPORATIONS.
RELATIVE TO THEIR COMPLIANCE
WITH CORPORATIONS CODE FIFTY
NINE THIRTEEN. BUT 75% OR MORE
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
SUBSTANTIALLY ALL. ACCORDINGLY
ARE REQUESTED AMENDMENT ALIGN
THE INFORMAL GUIDANCE PROVIDED
TO THOSE THAT MAY HAVE A NOTICE
OBLIGATION. UNDER SECTION FIFTY
NINE THIRTEEN. AS PREVIOUSLY WE
NOT A TO BE I FOR NOTICE. WE
ARE SIMPLY HOPING TO AVOID
AMBIGUITIES IN THE LAW AND ARE
SEEKING TO PROVIDE CLARITY TO
TRUSTEES. ENDEAVORING IN GOOD
FAITH TO COMPLY WITH A LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS THAT ARISE WITH
THIS NEW NOTICE REQUIREMENTS.
FOR THE REASONS STATED WE MUST
OPPOSE THE MEASURE TODAY UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MR GOLD IF YOU WOULD
STAY ON THE LINE FOR
QUESTIONING. THANK YOU ALL. ALL
RIGHT ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE
LINE EXCUSE ME LET ME TURN THE
GALLERY SAYING NO IN A GALLERY
SAYING NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. IN OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHT NINE ZERO ZERO ANYONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSITION IT A. B. NINE ZERO
ZERO. AND ON THE PHONE LINES
ARE IN OPPOSITION DAVY NINE
ZERO ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. CAN ONE ZERO
PROPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NONE IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE CHAMBER I SEE NO
ALL MICROPHONES RAISED IN THE
CHAMBER OF THE MISTER SENATOR
JONES IS UNDER JONES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANTED TO
GIVE THE AUTHOR A CHANCE TO
ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION'S.
CONCERN MIGHT MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THE OPPOSITE THEIR CONCERN
IS PRETTY SIMPLE IS WANTED
DEFINITION FOR WHAT
SUBSTANTIALLY ALL IS. AND IF
THE AUTHORS. AS STATED IN THE
OPENING A CONTINUE WORK ON A
WET AND WE JUST FIX IT HERE IN
JUDICIARY IN MINDEN AND THEN
MOVE IT ON- SO NUMBER RACE YOU
CAN RESPOND OR RESPOND IN YOUR
CLOTHES I DON'T MIND RESPONDING
AT THIS POINT I WOULD REFER. MY
COLLEAGUE TO PAGE SIX OF THE
MOUSE'S WHICH NOTES THE HISTORY
OF CALIFORNIA CODES NOTING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE DELIBERATELY
ELECTS TO USE THAT TERM. TO
ALLOW FLEXIBILITY AND
CONSIDERATION OF DIFFERENT
FACTS AND FACT PATTERNS INSTEAD
OF CODIFYING AN ARBITRARY
PERCENTAGE. THE TERM HAS BEEN
USED FOR MANY YEARS AND
CURRENTLY OVER TEN THOUSAND
NONPROFITS AND CHARITABLE
PICTURED CHARITIES COMPLY WITH
THIS REGULATION. FROM THE
ANALYSIS AND IF I MAY READ. FOR
THE PHRASE SUBSTANTIALLY ALL
ISN'T UNDEFINED TERM OF ART
USED THROUGHOUT THE CODES
SIMILAR PROVISIONS USING THIS
PHRASE THAT APPLY TO NON
PROFITS HAVE BEEN IN THE BOOKS
SINCE THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
AND DID NOT APPEAR TO HAVE
CAUSED SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE
PROBLEMS FURTHERMORE FROM AN
ENFORCEMENT PERSPECTIVE THERE
IS ARGUABLY VIRTUE IN SOME
DEGREE OF M. AND PRECISION IF
THE PHRASE IS DEFINED TO MEAN
EXACTLY 75% OR MORE OF THE
ASSETS. A TRUSTEE COULD AVOID
THE NOTICE REQUIREMENT BY
SELLING A FRACTION LESS
ASSUMING THE MARKET VALUE IS
READILY ASCERTAINABLE. USING A
GENERALLY UNDERSTOOD
LONGSTANDING TERM OF ART GIVES
YOU TURNING GENERAL'S OFFICE
FLEXIBILITY TO EXECUTE ITS
DUTIES IN A RANGE OF
SITUATIONS. FINALLY THE COST OF
COMPLIANCE IS MINIMAL. IN
BORDERLINE CASES A TRUSTEE CAN
ERR ON THE SIDE OF CAUTION BY
SIMPLYPROVIDING WRITTEN NOTICE.
THANK YOU- CENTER JONES. AS
GOOD AS ALL RIGHT- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS- SO I CASKEY.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THE
STAFF REPORT ON FOOTNOTE FOUR
SAYS THAT SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHT WHEN WE CHANGE
CORPORATION CODE THERE'S BEEN
NO PUBLISHED CASES ADDRESSING
THE MEANING OF THE PHRASE IN
EITHER THIS THE STATUTES THAT
THE- THE ASSEMBLYWOMAN- PUT IN
SO I WOULD HISTORICALLY A LOT
OF TIMES PEOPLE COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN THE SIX SIXTY
STRICKEN THE SECOND DISTRICT
HAVE A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION
AND THERE'S COMPETING LAW
WITHIN CITY OR INTERPRETATION
ALONG CALIFORNIA THEY ASKED FOR
THAT. CLARIFICATION THAT DOES
NOT SEEM THE CASE IN THIS
INSTANCE THANK YOU JUDGE WHAT
KOWSKI ALL RIGHT- OTHER
COMMENTS. OTHER COMMENTS NO
OBVIOUS CENTER COVER EUROPE.
MOVE THE BILL THE COUPLE EUROS
BILL ONE QUICK QUESTION MR
GOULD- AND I TAKE YOUR POINT
WITH RESPECT TO SOME AMBIGUITY
AS TO SUBSTANTIALLY ALL ARM AND
WE DON'T WANT TO NEGOTIATE THE
LANGUAGE HERE IN COMMITTEE BUT
IF IT WERE 50% OR MORE WITH
THAT ADDRESS YOUR CONCERNS.
INSTEAD OF SUBSTANTIALLY ALL-
IF WE SUBSTITUTE THE TERM 50%
OR MORE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR I MEAN I
THINK WE ARE SOMEWHAT AGNOSTIC
WITH RESPECT TO WHAT THE
PERCENTAGE IS SO LONG AS WE
UNDERSTAND. WHAT CAUSES THE
OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE NOTICE SO
IF FOR EXAMPLE. INITIALLY ALL
MEANT MORE THAN A MAJORITY AT
51% OR MORE OF THE ASSETS. WE
WOULD AT LEAST HAVE A GREATER
CERTAINTY- WE WOULD NOT OPPOSE
THAT IT WOULD PROVIDED GREATER
CERTAINTY. WITH RESPECT TO WHAT
CARDS NOTICE TO BE PROVIDED
UNDER THE NEW PROVISION. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- ALL RIGHT.
BETTER TO CANCEL THE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS AB NINE HUNDRED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADVANCE WITH
A MOTION BY SENATOR KERR YET
ALL THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AMBERG.
HI AMBERG HI PURCHASE THOUGH
WAGES NO. ZERO FIVE ZERO I DID
ASAL HI THE DRESS SO I.
GONZALEZ HI WHEN SELES I HURTS
BERG. JONES NO JONES KNOWS
LAYERED HI LAYERED I STERN.
WHITE HOUSE SKI HI WHY CASKEY I
WINNER. WINNER I. YOU HAVE
SEVENTY TWO SO FAR ALL RIGHT
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL ALL
RIGHT LAST KILL AB ONE ZERO
NINE SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOSE
THREE OF US- AFTER THIS WE WILL
LIFT THE CALLS ON THE BILL SO
IF YOU WISH YOUR VOTE TO BE
RECORDED NOW WOULD BE A GOOD
TIME TO PRESENT YOURSELF TO THE
SENATE CHAMBER. ALL RIGHT.
SALUTE MEMBER LOSE THREE OF US.
AB. ONE ZERO NINE SIX. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS
I'M HONORED TO PRESENT ABC TEN
NINETY SIX A LATINO AND JEWISH
CAUCUS PRIORITY AB TEN NINETY
SIX DELETES THE OUTDATED AND
OFFENSIVE TERM ALIEN WHICH IS
FOUND THROUGHOUT OUR STATE LAWS
AND REPLACES IT WITH
APPROPRIATE LEGAL TERMINOLOGY
SUCH AS NON CITIZEN. WHILE THIS
CHANGE MAY SEEM SIMPLE IT HAS
SIGNIFICANT IMPLICATIONS
ALTHOUGH THE TERM ALIEN HAS
HISTORICALLY REFERRED TO
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE NON
CITIZENS THE WORD WAS SINCE HAS
SINCE BEEN WEAPONIZED AND USED
IN PLACE OF AN EXPLICITLY
RACIAL SLUR. THERE'S A DIRECT
LINK BETWEEN WORDS AND ACTIONS
DEHUMANIZING LANGUAGE OFTEN
PRECEDES VILE ACTIONS WE'VE
SEEN A MULTITUDE OF RECENT
INCIDENTS THAT OUR COUNTRY
CONTINUES TO REEL FROM RACIST
VIOLENCE. AB TEN NINETY SIX
INSURERS CALIFORNIA'S LAWS
CONSISTENT TERMINOLOGY THAT
ALIGNS WITH OUR WITH OUR
IDEALS. TODAY I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THAT WILL PROVIDE
TESTIMONY FIRST- MISS THE LOTUS
WHERE OUR CIVIL RIGHTS
CHAMPION. AND MISS NANCY APPEAL
WITH THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE.
I THANK YOU SIMPLY WOMAN- THIS
WHERE TOUGH YOU'RE AVAILABLE.
HI YES I AM ALL RIGHT NEAR ME
YES GO AHEAD AS WELL YES YES WE
HEAR YOU GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- TERMINAL NUMBER AND
THE US SENATORS AS THAT ON THIS
COMMITTEE I WANNA THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO CATCH A PLANE TO
PUT THAT ONE REALLY THANK THE
ALLUDES WE RECOMMEND BELOW THE
SIGNATURE. OF PRESENTING THE
BUILD FOR YOU- AND SHE SAID
EARLIER. THIS IS A WORD THAT
LITERALLY NEED TO BE TAKEN OUT.
OF ALL THE CALIFORNIA STATE LAW.
IT YOU KNOW IT STARTED WITH THE-
TO DO ACTS IN SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT CLICK TONIGHT THAT WOULD
DIRECTLY AIMED AT. THE NON
IMMIGRANT TO- THAT BANKING TO
MEDITATE IN AMERICA AND-
APPROVED THROUGH THE HISTORY
BOOKS THAT THOMAS JEFFERSON
WOULD OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT HAS
REMAINED IN OUR LANGUAGE AND IF
WE LOOK AT RIGHT NOW IS THE
TIME THAT EVERYONE IS WORKING
SO THAT WE CAN REMEDY. OUR
RESEARCH HISTORY. IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. ARE WE DOING
NEED THIS KIND OF LINES. TO BE
AND IN ANY OF OUR LONG. A WE
KNOW IS THAT THE GERMAN WOMAN
LEADER SAID THAT WORDS DO
MATTER. AND THAT THIS IS THE
TIME WHERE WE CAN REALLY
BENEFIT LIMIT EITHER AND
CORRECT IT. WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN KILLED BECAUSE THAT
ASIAN WOMEN. IN THE STATE OF
GEORGIA A PEOPLE OF A CERTAIN
EXTRACTION IN THE PAST SO
TEXAS. THAT WOULD CHILDREN
BECAUSE THEY WERE MEXICAN AND
WE DO NEED TO GET AWAY FROM ALL
OF THIS. IT'S JUST RHETORIC
THAT LEADS RIGHT NOW OFFICIAL
INSPECTING- IN DESTROYING OUR
DEMOCRACY SO THIS IS ONE GIANT
STEP THAT WE CAN MAKE AND- I
KNOW THAT MANY OF YOU A LITTLE
BOOKLET RIGHT WE UNDERSTAND. I
DON'T WANT TO SEE I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE WANT TO WORK VERY
HARD. TO HAVE A HUMANE IN THE
HURCH OR SOCIETY IN A
DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY IN THE
UNITED STATES SO. AGAIN ONE
STEP THAT WE CAN TAKE TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN HAPPENED LIKE
ELIMINATING THE WORD ALIENS
FROM ALL CALIFORNIA ON. THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH THE FOCUS. THANK
YOU FOR YOU MISS WHERE TO IT
BEFORE TURN TO NEXT WOULD I
NOTE THAT WE HAVE TO GUESTS IN
THE GAL- THIS IS LOW THIS.
RETURNING TO CAPISTRANO MAY.
THAT THE SEASON IS CHANGING SO
THANK YOU FOR BEING OUR FIRST
THREE GUESS. THIS NANCY APPEAL
FROM THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE.%
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS NANCY APPEL AND I
SERVED AS LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE
FIVE CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
OFFICES. BUT I'M I'M IN
NINETEEN THIRTEEN IN RESPONSE
TO AN ESCALATING CLIMATE OF
ANTI SEMITISM AND BIGOTRY ADL
HAS NOW BECOME A LEADING ANTI
HATE ORGANIZATIONS. WE HAVE
LONG ADVOCATED FOR FAIR AND
HUMANE IMMIGRATION POLICIES AND
WORLD LEADER IN EXPOSING THE
ANTI IMMIGRANT AND ANTI REFUGEE
HATE. THE NATIONAL DISCOURSE
AROUND IMMIGRATION. WITHOUT
MAKING SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES TO
ANY LAW AB TEN NINETY SIX WILL
REMOVE THE OFFENSIVE TERM ALIEN
FROM STATE STATUTES WHEN
REFERRING TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE NOT CITIZENS AND REPLACE IT
WITH MORE INCLUSIVE INITIAL
TERM. IMPORTING ALIEN TO
DESCRIBE A PERSON IN THE
HUMANIZING. FORTUNATELY A FORUM
IT HAS BECOME A CODE WORD FOR
ANTI IMMIGRANT BIGOTRY AT ADL
FOR EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS-
DIRECTED AT ABOUT PROVIDING
ANTI BIAS EDUCATION FOR
TEACHERS AND STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE IN THE COUNTRY YOU
KNOW THAT WORDS MATTER AND THAT
WORDS LIKE ALIEN CAN CAUSE WILL
HARM. BRING WITHOUT PUSHING
ADDED. AND USING TERMS LIKE
ALIEN TO REFER TO HUMAN BEINGS
COMING TO PREJUDICE
DISCRIMINATION AND VIOLENCE. BY
KEEPING THE GRADING TERMINAR
STATUTE WE CONTINUE TO
NORMALIZE. THE FUSE DESPITE THE
PAIN IT CAUSES. EIGHTY TWO
NINETY SIX PROVIDING. TO
IMPROVE THE NARRATIVE AROUND
IMMIGRATION AND WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THEY GIVE A SPIEL ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT I SEE NO ONE
IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE OTHERS ON THE
PHONE LINE AND SUPPORT
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD QUEUE
THEM UP. AND IF YOU'RE ON THE
PHONE PLEASE JUST PROVIDE YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION. ALL RIGHT MODERATE DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT. IN RELATED
GERMAN IN SUPPORT OF A V. TEN
NINETY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN ONE
ZERO FOR SUPPORT. WE DO FIVE IN
OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT GO AHEAD.
WE'LL START WITH LINE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR THIS IS SETH BROWN BOTH
SPEAKING THIS AFTERNOON BUT NOT
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND EDUCATORS THE MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION STRONG COHORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANKS
THANK YOU. LINE FORTY TWO IS
NEXT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JANET POPS
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ONE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTER NEARLY
ANY PACKAGE AND WE HAVE A TAX
NET INCOME SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
JENNIFER GONZALES CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE OFFICE OF THE
TENET GOVERNOR LENNY COULD
UNLOCK IT IT'S A PART OF AT TEN
NINETY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS
IN QUEUE FOR SUPPORT ALL RIGHT
CONTINUE. LET'S TURN OUT
OPPOSITION I NOTE THAT THERE
ARE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- ROLE RODRIGUEZ AND
STELLA MAY. MISTER RODRIGUEZ
ARE YOU ON THE PHONE OR MISS ME
ARE YOU ON THE PHONE. WHEN DO
WE GET TO START IS THAT MISS
MAY. I GUESS- WINDOWS MY TWO
MINUTE YET ARE YOU RIGHT NOW.
WELL ACTUALLY IT TAKES TWENTY
SECONDS TO SAY MY NAME AND CORN
WILL SLOW MY NAME IS DYLAN MAY
I MEAN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CONCERNED CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA AND MY TWO MINUTE
STARTS NOW. BRIEFLY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ONE OH NINE SIX
BECAUSE FIRST THE VARIOUS NEW
MULTI WORD PHRASES USED TO
REPLACE THE UNIVERSAL WORD
ALIEN ARE UTTERLY CONFUSING AND
HAVE NO COMMON THREAD TO ANY US
CODES LAWS STATUTES FORMS A
GREEN CARDS FOR THE NATIONAL
ENUMERATION SYSTEM THAT ASSIGNS
UNIQUE IDENTIFIERS ONE OF WHICH
IS ALIEN. SECONDLY WHILE A. B.
TEN NINETY SIX CLAIMS TO MAKE
QUOTE NON SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES
AND QUOTE BY REPLACING THE WORD
ALIEN WITH WHAT MULTI WORDED
PHRASES FROM ALL CALIFORNIA
CODES NOTHING COULD BE FURTHER
FROM THE TRUTH THE TERM ILLEGAL
ALIEN WAS FIRST COINED. IN
SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT IN THE
ALIEN AND SEDITION ACTS SINCE
THAT TIME LITERALLY MILLIONS IF
NOT BILLIONS OF U. S. AND STATE
LAWS BOOKS ETCETERA USING
ALIENS AS A UNIQUE IDENTIFIER
SO TO CLAIM THIS BILL IS MAKING
NINE SUBSTANDARD CHANGES IN. IS
AN OUTRIGHT FALSE SKIS ME FELL
PAULSON MILLIONS OF CHANGES ARE
IN FACT QUITE SOME STANDARDS.
ISO NINE THOUSAND IS V. WORLD'S
BEST KNOWN HARMONIZE QUALITY
MANAGEMENT STANDARD THE TERM
ALIEN IS ALSO A HARMONIZED IN
STANDARD TERM USED AROUND THE
WORLD. IN FACT LAFAYETTE USES
NICKEL SONY MARKED ON PASSPORTS
WHICH MEANS BAILEY AND FOR
CALIFORNIA TO REPLACE A
STANDARD WORD WITH DIFFERENT
PHRASES LITERALLY MEANS YOUR
NEW BILL WILL BE SUBSTANDARD.
ALIEN REGISTRATION NUMBERS ARE
ASSIGNED TO EVERYONE WHO
APPLIES FOR A GREEN CARD CAN
YOU IMAGINE TRYING TO FIT
PHRASES ONTO A GREEN CARD. LAST
WEEK THE WORD ALIEN WAS USED IN
NO LESS THAN THREE TIMES IN A
UNANIMOUS OPINION WRITTEN BY
JUSTICE KAGAN JUST SEVEN DAYS
AGO TITLED. SANCHEZ BEAT MY
YORK AND ARE YOU REALLY GO. TO
SCHOOL THE SUPREME COURT IN
WHAT. THEY CAN AND CANNOT USE.
THEY ARE OBLIGED TO YOU THE
WORD ALIEN BECAUSE IT IS.
EVERYWHERE IT IS UBIQUITOUS IT
IS INTERNATIONAL
INTERNATIONALLY KNOWS. A. B.
TEN NINETY SIX IS A PANDORA'S
BOX OF CONFUSION PLEASE VOTE NO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR THE GUIDANCE ON
COMMITTEE OPERATION ALL RIGHT
NEXT MR RODRIGUEZ. MR REAGAN'S
ARE YOU AVAILABLE. YEAH CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
ROLLED OUT BIGGEST JUNIOR THE
CALIFORNIA COORDINATOR FOR
AMERICA FIRST LATINOS I AM A
PROUD FIRST GENERATION SON OF A
MEXICAN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT.
NATURALIZED CITIZEN WHO SERVED
IN WORLD WAR TWO. AS AN ARMY
MEDIC- SERVICE ACCOUNT. PLEASE
STATE ALEX LIVES INDIVIDUAL IN
IN HIS DIVISION. BUT I MEAN AT
THE FRONTLINE IN GERMANY. I AM
YES I AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THE ENTIRE ASSEMBLY BILL AB
TEN NINETY SIX. THE ALIEN
CHANGE TERMS THE MEDICATION.
RELEGATION BECAUSE FIRST THE
BILL IS TRYING TO CHANGE AN
EASY TO UNDERSTAND WORD ALIEN.
TO SEVERAL DIFFERENT PHRASES
SECOND. THE REPLACEMENT PLACES
ARE THEY HAD NOWHERE IN ANY U.
S. LOG STANDS. BRITAIN SINCE
NINETEEN SINCE SEVENTEEN NINETY
EIGHT THIRD THE BILL APPEARS TO
BE. KLUBER THE TRUE MEANING OF
WHAT ALIEN MEANS AND MAKES IT
HARD TO DISTINGUISH WHO IS
ILLEGAL AND WHO IS LEGAL. WHAT
AN INSULT. NOT ONLY TO MY
NATURALIZED FATHER BUT TO THE
MANY OTHER MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
WHO BECAME NATURALIZED CITIZENS
WHO WORKED HARD TO APPLY FOR
AND RECEIVE CITIZENSHIP AND NO
LONGER. TO BE CONSIDERED A
FOREIGN ALIEN IT IS A STATUS
SYMBOL TO THOSE WHO BECOME
NATURALIZED AND IT TAKES AND TO
TAKE THAT AWAY IS A HUGE STEP
OF PRIDE. WORDS DO MATTER AND A
U. S. CITIZEN AND US CITIZENS
HAVE A FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT TO
CALL ANYONE WHO IS NOT IN THE
US CITIZEN AND ALIEN A RESIDENT
ALIEN OR- SOME OTHER. DEFINED
STATUS COMMONLY USED IN OUR
LAWS AND CODES THAT INCLUDES
THE WORD ALIEN. THANK YOU.
SIMILARLY CHARMING US THE MONEY
THANK YOU SIR. ALL RIGHT-
ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NONE OF
ALTHOUGH I DO WELCOME FOR MORE
GUESTS IN THE GALLERY AND-
ANYONE ELSE- IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
IN OPPOSITION SEEING NONE LET'S
TURN THE PHONE LINE THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE LINE
PLEASE QUEUE UP GIVE US YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION. WHO PLAYS JOHN IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. I LOOK SO
WE DO HAVE A THREE IN OUR QUEUE
ALL RIGHT GO AHEAD. SO WE'LL
START WITH LINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN GO WE CAN
HEAR YOU. MY NAME IS GREG OPERA
HANYON SANTA CLARITA CALIFORNIA.
HE'S A NO ON THIS THANK YOU
NEXT. LINE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE WILL REQUIRE
CONCERNED CITIZEN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE TEN NINETY. THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I. SO NO RESPONSE AT THE TIME-
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN OUR
QUEUE ALL RIGHT HE CONTINUED A
STRAIGHT BACKED CHAIR I SEE
SENT A GOOD SOLACE IN CENTER
THE ROSSES MICROPHONES UP SOON
TO CONSOLIDATE. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND COMMEND
HER FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD-
YOU KNOW WE MAY. WE'VE BEEN
HEARING FROM BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION ABOUT THEIR FEELINGS
ABOUT THIS BUT QUITE FRANKLY WE
KNOW AND MY GRANDMOTHER MY
MOTHER- IN THE PAST AND THEIR
DOCUMENTS HAD BEEN CALLED. AN
ALIEN BEFORE AND IT HURTS IT IS
DEHUMANIZING IT'S VERY
UNSOPHISTICATED WORD AT THIS
TIME- OUTDATED IN VERY HOT
STYLE AND SO I'M GLAD THAT WE
ARE NOW TURNING THE CURVE AND
WE CAN BE AN EXAMPLE FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO CONTINUE
TO PUSH. FORWARD IN ALL FEDERAL
LAWS. AS WE KNOW ICE IN ITSELF
IS NOT EVEN UTILIZING THIS TERM
NOT UTILIZING ALIEN THEY'RE NOT
USE LIGHT UTILIZING
ASSIMILATION BECAUSE THAT IS
NOT PROPER IT'S AGAIN VERY
UNSOPHISTICATED. AND WE HAVE
MOVED ON FROM THAT ESPECIALLY
IF CALIFORNIA IS INVESTING SO
MUCH IN OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES. PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED AND MAY NOT BE
CITIZENS WHICH WOULD BE THE
PROPER WAY TO TURN. A TITLE
FOLKS. SO WITH THAT WE'D BE
HAPPY TO- SUPPORT THIS IF I'M
NOT A CO AUTHOR WOULD LOVE TO
BE ADDED AS WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR. ALSO TO CONSIDER THE
RUSSELL. THANK YOU MR CHAIR-
THIS IS THE LATINO CAUCUS A
PRIORITY. BILL FOR I THINK
OBVIOUS REASONS AND I DO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR HAD NOT.
EVER OCCURRED TO ME. THAT THIS
TERM WAS STILL USED- IN OUR-
LAWS- THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT
WHEN SOMEBODY USES IT- THEY
REALLY ARE. INTENDING TO
OFFEND. AMERICANS OF LATINO
DESCENT. AW THEY DON'T KNOW THE
STATUS OF THAT PERSON THEY'RE
NOT USING IT FOR LEGAL REASONS.
THEY'RE USING IT TO OFFEND. THE
USING THAT TO SAY. YOU DON'T
BELONG HERE YOU'RE AN ALIEN- WE
HAVE HAD THIS STRUGGLE OVER
TERMINOLOGY AND WORDS ITH THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA FOR MANY
DECADES. WITH THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY THERE WAS A LARGE LAW
ARTICLE LONG ARTICLE IN THE LA
TIMES ABOUT. LATINOS AND HOWARD
PROJECTED IN THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY WORDS LEAD TO IMAGES
IMAGES LEAD TO OTHER THINGS SO
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR I'M
SO PROUD THAT SHE IS TAKING
THIS UP. ON AND I HOPE IT
SERVES AS A WAY TO. EDUCATE
OURSELVES NOT TO USE THIS KIND
OF TERMINOLOGY WHEN REFERRING.
TO A HUMAN BEINGS ARE NOT
ALIENS FROM ANOTHER PLANET.
THANK YOU PACER THAT ALSO
ANYONE ELSE I SEE NO OTHER
MICROPHONES- I WANT TO JOIN IN
THANKING YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LUIS REIS RIVERS I WANT TO
THANK THE OPPOSITION AS WELL
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THERE
COULD HAVE BEEN A CLEAR
ILLUSTRATIONS TO THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS BILL AND THEN WAS
PRESENTED BY THE OPPOSITION. SO
IS THERE A MOTION. YES I KNOW I
CAN HE MOVES THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT- I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF YOU KNOW SINCE THIS
TERM ALIEN WAS CREATED. IT HAS
BEEN WEAPONIZED TO TAKE ON A
DIFFERENT MEANING A MEANING TO
INCITE HATE TO TELL SOME OF US
THAT WE DON'T BELONG HERE. A
CONTRARY TO WHAT ONE OF THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION STATED
YOU KNOW MY MOM IS ALSO A
NATURALIZED CITIZENSHIP BECAME
A NATURALIZED CITIZEN IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES AND SHE IS
NOT PROUD. OF THE WORD ALIEN
AND TO CONTINUE TO USE THAT
WORD ON OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S TIME TO END THIS AN AB TEN
NINETY SIX AND IS THAT IN OUR
STATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHTY THANK YOU MEANT TO
CANCEL IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS ABC TEN NINETY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOOSE LEAVE
US WITH. THAT MOTION BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI THE MOTION IS
DO YOU PASS ON BURKE- BURGER I
APOLOGIZE ZERO. BOARD IS NO
PROBABLY AT ALL I KNOW YOU KNOW
I DID SO LONG THE REST SO I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. I HURTS
BERG. JONES NO JONES NO. WAY HI
THERE I STERN FIVE STERN I WAKE
HOUSE SKI HI. WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER WINNER HI. FIVE SIX.
FORMER YOU HAVE EIGHT TWO ZERO
AND THAT THE ENTIRE I THINK
THAT THAT BILL IS OUT ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA LIVE CALLS HERE IN
JUST A MOMENT- I THINK WE'VE
GOT A FULL HOUSE- SO LET'S
LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
LIFTING CALLS HERE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'D COPY AT ALL. HI
KERRY AT ALL I. AM SORRY
HERTZBERG. STERN HI STERN I
WINNER. WINNER HI THAT'S TEN
ZERO. THE BILLS OUT. AT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IT'LL ANSWER
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT
ADOPTED THANK YOU WELL. SIR
NEXT BILL IS EIGHTY TO SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS STONE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I'D PROBABLY IT'LL
I CARRY IT ALL I HURTS BERG.
STERN BY STERN I WINNER HI
WINNER HI THAT'S TEN TWO ZERO.
BILLS I'LL- NEXT IS A B. TWO
SEVENTY TWO- WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I. HERTZBERG STERN HI
STEARN HI WINNER WINNER I
THAT'S TEN TWO ZERO. BILLS OUT.
THE NEXT BILL IS. EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY THREE. WITH AT BAY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVIES WITH THAT
SHARE VOTING I HURTS BURKE.
EASTERN HI STERN HI WEINER.
WEINER I THAT'S TEN TWO ZERO
THOSE OUT. AT THE NEXT BILL IS
AB EIGHT SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I. GORGEOUS OKAY
HERTZBERG EASTERN HI TURN I
WENT TO THREE AND FOUR HI.
THIRTY EIGHT TO ONE BILLS OUT.
THE NEXT BILL IS A. B. AND NINE
HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TRAVIS WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
HURTS BURKE. STERN BY STERN I.
THAT'S EIGHT TO TWO BILLS OUT.
AND THAT'S EVERYTHING ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
ADJOURN AND RECONVENE NEXT
TUESDAY AT ONE THIRTY THANK YOU.